- Telling to an Asian
parent, after their son
has just gone through
four years of university
to get a master's degree,
and then get a job
at the BBC, that they're gonna quit that
to talk about anime titties.
- If you were my son,
I would be angry at you.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
- Hello, and welcome to
another episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host for today,
Gigg, United Kingdom, Arizona.
(Chris laughs)
And with me today,
are my usual co-hosts, the
93% and the Hentai Boy.
- That's me.
- And today we also have our
very first guest with us today.
- Official guest!
- Who are you?
- Do you want to introduce yourself?
- I'm Chris and I make YouTube videos,
on YouTube about Japan.
- What's your channel name?
- Abroad In Japan, it's a clever pun
because my surname is Broad, Abroad.
It's really clever.
- That took me a long time
to figure out actually,
because when I heard that you were like,
oh yeah, I'm Chris Broad.
- Holy shit, I just fucking got that now!
(laughs)
- Oh, I didn't know that.
- Are you serious?
- No, I'm just like
holy shit that's genius!
Wait a minute, abroad like...
- I didn't realize that.
- Because when you said that,
you were like, my name is Chris Broad.
- I didn't say my name is Chris Broad.
(Gigg laughs)
Did I?
- Because I heard like
the Abroad In Japan thing
and I was like, it's probably a pun,
but I'm like it's too good to be a pun.
- Yeah, good.
- It's that good.
- Yeah, it's a little too coincidental.
- I was like, Chris Broad
can't be your real name.
- How long did it take
you to come up with that,
or was it just like--
- I don't even remember,
even my first year.
I've always hated the name Broad,
Chris Broad just sounds awful,
like I'm Chris Broad and people go ew.
- I wish I could have like,
a second name that's easy to pronounce.
- Broad.
- Broad, you can't fuck it up, can you?
- You can't fuck it up.
But when I came to Japan,
I thought, wait a minute,
I can actually use my name for once,
in a pun that's clever.
- Oh my God.
- But I didn't tell people
my name was Chris Broad,
until three years into doing YouTube.
- Oh, really?
- And then when I was like,
Chris Broad, people were
like wow, that's clever.
- (laughs) Wow, that's clever!
- Because like, I think--
- I'll laugh that joke for three years.
(laughs)
- I think that's more effort than,
either of us put into like
our usernames combined.
- You're telling me?
- The Anime Man, how did you come up
with that name Joey?
- I'm a man who likes anime, end of story.
- That's an interesting point actually,
because you've kind of like
solidified yourself into anime.
- I've really fucked
myself in that aspect.
I can't do anything else now.
At least Abroad In Japan, right?
It's basic enough.
- My point was gonna be,
that's kind of the same boat,
where like, do you feel like you could
maybe branch out with that name like that?
- Well, like what? Abroad In Taiwan?
- Yeah, just like the second channel,
Abroad In Kazakhstan, coming soon.
(laughs)
- Joey, before we answer that,
do you wanna explain what kind of content?
We're getting ahead of ourselves.
- Sorry Chris.
- Do you wanna explain what
kind of content you do?
- Just about Japan innit?
(Gigg laughs)
I'm really bad at selling myself.
- I feel like if anyone has watched
a video about like life in
Japan or an experience in Japan,
odds are they've come across your channel.
- I hope so.
- I mean, you are technically
the biggest J-Vlogger right now, right?
- Yeah.
- I think you are.
- In terms of sub size, I'm pretty sure.
- All the comments are gonna be filled,
he's not, he's rubbish,
there's that one and this one.
- Sorry, go ahead.
- Because whenever I was
watching videos about Japan,
you would be the name
that would always pop up,
and this is like going back years ago.
We'll get back to that in a bit,
but for now do you wanna open
our beers boys?
- Oh yeah.
- Go for the beverages boys.
- I was just eyeing this up for ages
and I'm like, can we just open beers?
- Let's get some ASMR going.
(cans clicking)
(exhales loudly)
- Smells good.
(speaking in foreign language)
- So like I think a good topic for today,
- That's good. It's a good move, Joey.
Joey chose Pineapple Strong Zero.
- I didn't know Kirin had like a brand
of Strong Zeros now.
- It's called Kirin, the strong.
- The Strong.
- The Strong,
so it must be better than Strong Zero.
- Kirin's prime sell.
- If any of you ever come to Japan
and there's one beverage
you should try out,
if you do drink beverages, alcoholically,
then Strong Zero.
- Or The Strong.
- This is like what we
call the Gaijin Killer,
is what you guys called it, right?
- It's colloquially the Gaijin Killer.
- Absolutely.
- Because it tastes like
juice, but then you realize
it's just as strong as like a wine.
- Yeah.
- So you just get fucked.
- But like percentage-wise
it's as strong as a wine.
I don't know why, it
fucks me up way harder
than any wine I've ever had.
- This is carbonated,
I think, I don't know.
- Maybe, I think I've blacked
out every time, I've had one.
(Garnt laughs)
When Strong Zero's involved in a night,
I ended up normally not remembering.
- Strong Zero hangovers are
easily the worst, I reckon.
- But the last time we
drank Strong Zero's,
like I don't remember 1/2 that night.
(Joey laughing)
And then I woke up with like
the most searing headache, I was like...
(exhales loudly)
- Yeah, it's horrible.
- Do you guys remember your
first Strong Zero experience?
- Yeah, it was at--
- No, I blacked out.
(laughs)
- When I was a teacher up in North Japan
we had like an end-of-year
party every year,
and that was like the
one drink everyone drank.
And I just woke up on
a beach at 5 a.m. like
face down in the sand.
(laughs)
Surrounded by six cans of Strong Zero,
like , six cans, it was formidable.
One is like, you feel it.
Two is like, whoa.
Three is like, oh God no!
And after that it's blackout phase.
How long did it take you, Connor, for you?
- I think it was like the very first time,
I think it was like three or four.
- Three or four.
- And I can normally handle
my alcohol pretty well,
- It doesn't matter, it's
something about Strong Zero.
It doesn't matter how much you think
you can hold alcohol.
After three Strong Zero's, it's like
inhumane territory, no one can handle it.
- Because we're like
three Brits and an Aussie.
We're very used to drinking, but for some.
And here's the thing,
every time I see someone
who tries Strong Zero,
especially if they're from the UK,
they're like, this is 9%?
This isn't gonna fuck me up! Please.
And then they have like two cans
and they're like, wasted already.
And then third can is like, I'm blackout,
I cannot remember this night.
And I don't know what it is
about this particular drink.
- Shochu.
- Maybe this Shochu?
- It's the greatest prank you can pull
on your friends though, when
you bring them to Japan.
(laughs)
Like, give him three, it's just
like fizzy water, it's fine!
And then things happen.
- It's crazy that businessmen
just drink them, like,
I see them at like, I
think 1 p.m. sometimes
just having one outside the combini.
I'm like, damn.
- Well if it's the PM,
it's time to drink, isn't it?
- Yeah, honestly.
Seriously, they're not
playing around here.
I'm like damn, okay.
- They've gotta optimize
all the free time they have,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, exactly.
- I've gotta be back
to work in 20 minutes.
- I think I can slip one in.
(all laugh)
- So I guess a good
topic to talk about today
is basically, I guess our
origin stories of YouTube
and just our thoughts
on YouTubers in general.
Because we're all three YouTubers,
normally we just have anime YouTubers on,
but now we have like someone else
who does something a bit different.
- Someone else.
- Who would've thought that
the first official guest
of this anime podcast
is someone who has no idea about anime.
- I've seen Satoshi Kon and.
- Like in person?
(Gigg laughs)
- In person, down at the pub.
No yeah, it's true, I'm in
the church of like, anime.
Like three, massive anime YouTubers.
It feels like I've committed
a crime just by being here.
It's a sacred holy ground.
- No, it's really weird right,
because you've watched Satoshi Kon,
which is more cultured
than a lot of anime fans,
who are very much into anime.
- One of the priests
hasn't watched any of them.
- I haven't watched any
Satoshi Kon, so I guess,
yeah, I know I'm terrible.
Look, he's laughing at me!
(laughs)
- I'm laughing 'cause he referred to you
as one of the priests.
(Joey laughs)
- I didn't refer to myself
as one of the priests.
- Anime is a church, right?
- I think we need to rebrand this podcast,
The Priests of Anime.
(all laugh)
- The Anime Church and
we're the three priests.
- Family-friendly,
Priests of Anime Channel.
- Well then that's perfect, right,
so like hopefully by the end of it,
we can hopefully try and convince Chris
to like maybe give a few of
our recommendations a go.
- And then Chris--
- Definitely.
can hopefully pursue Connor,
and everybody who's watching
or listening that doesn't know
anything about Satoshi Kon,
to watch Satoshi Kon.
- I agree. That's a good challenge.
- Think you're up to that task, Chris?
- I'm for it. Like I'm open-minded.
Like anime I watch is good, it's just
I never really got into it as kid really,
apart from "Pokemon" or,
I mean I watched "Digimon",
as we talked about Joey,
and just that put me off.
(Gnart laughs)
I'm under the impression that "Digimon"
isn't the most respected anime, so.
- It's got it's diehard fan base, I think.
- Are you part of that fan base?
- No, but I know, I think
I made a joke about it
and there's like a new season.
People got pissed at me when I said
I'm not watching that.
- It's 'cause it's like a lot
of people's childhood, right.
Because I grew up on "Digimon."
So I mean, I wouldn't
say I'm a diehard fan
but I definitely enjoyed it as a kid.
- I played the game.
I don't know which ones I played,
but I remember that.
- Oh, I didn't get that far.
- I played like that Smash Bros Knockoff.
That was pretty fun I think.
- There was a Smash Bros Knockoff?
- Yeah, "Digimon: Rumble
Arena" it was called.
They made like three of them.
- Were you aware of that?
- No, I wasn't aware of that.
The only thing I'm aware of guys
is just the theme tune stuck in my head.
(Gigg laughs)
- It's not even the good one,
I know, it's the English one.
At least like--`
- Bro, the English one's the
good one, what can I say?
- If you listen to the Japanese
opening, it's fucking epic.
It's like the, you probably
heard it, it's like the,
(Joey singing in foreign language)
- Oh, that's the song I hear at karaoke!
- So it's completely different.
♪ Digimon, digital monsters. ♪
- No, they pulled a "Dragon Ball Z".
Dragon Ball Z Japanese opening
was like actual proper songs,
and the English one was just.
♪ Jerk it, jerk it, move, jerk it. ♪
It was like--
- Boy, that was hype though,
- Come on, come on!
- It was a hype opening but I just love
how it's like, all right.
We got a show called "Dragon Ball Z."
(others laughing)
How many times can we see
the title of the story
in the song?
- Bro, that's like big brain mode though.
(laughs)
- I think the only other
lyric is come get me.
- Yeah exactly, right!
- In the "Dragon Ball" opening?
- I do not remember this at all.
- You don't remember the
English "Dragon Ball" opening?
- No, I think it's like, I forgot that.
- It's so Epic, like--
- It's so iconic though,
how do you forget?
- The guitar intros, the
(Joey imitates intense guitar)
- I think the "One Piece" rap
is like, blocked out all
childhood English openings for me.
- I had the pleasure of
not growing up with that.
- What do you mean, pleasure?
You had the displeasure.
- So my question to you then Chris,
because a lot, obviously in our circles,
a lot of people we know came to Japan
or moved to Japan, like
based on somewhat based
on their love for anime.
And, that's us included.
So like, why did you
choose to move to Japan
if anime wasn't like a
big reason or any reason?
- Yeah, that's asked a lot.
I always feel like
guilty by coming to Japan
and not knowing anime or Otaku culture.
- I mean, it's fine.
- Growing up. Japan was everything to me.
So, such an amazing,
mystical, wonderful country.
Everything I used, everything I did,
every craze was Japanese in some way,
from Pokemon to Nintendo, Sony.
My first camcorder that
I often used was Sharp.
Japan always felt like a country,
I wanted to try and visit, and I go to
But being British, if you look at a map
of where Japan is and where the UK is,
we're not going there.
(the rest laugh)
It's so far. To North American viewers,
though obviously it's
still pretty damn far.
If you look at the map it's like,
it's not that far, it's the water.
But Japan is so damn far.
And so I thought, I'm not gonna go there.
But then I thought about teaching English.
And Japan came up as an option,
and it was the only country,
I ever thought I'd wanna teach English in,
and actually immerse myself
and learn about the culture.
So in a nutshell, that was kind of it.
- So even before all of that,
like you were already
set on leaving the UK
at one point, or?
- Absolutely, I always
wanted to live overseas
and travel somewhere in Asia.
- So where would have
been your second option
if you never got to Japan?
- I was going to ask that.
- Second option?
I don't know if there was
a second option in Asia.
It was kind of like Japan or nothing.
- Okay, oh, wow.
- Just Japanese culture really excited me,
like all the stuff, I had seeing about it.
- Because I watched your
first video last night.
I was doing some research too.
And the vibe you gave off almost was like,
" All right lads, I'm in Japan."
(all laugh)
You know what I mean,
like I've just landed--
- Lads on tour!
- It's kinda like, I just ended in Japan.
Might fuck around and stay a little bit.
(all laugh)
So I got the impression, I just thought
it was like a thing where you were like
all right, fuck it, might move to Japan.
You know, that's kind of like the vibe
I got from the video, I guess.
But obviously hearing
that I'm kind of shocked.
But then I could also see a British person
not wanting to seem like
obsessed with something
because that's uncool in British culture.
- Yeah.
- No, it's not that. I
mean the trouble is like,
most people who come into
Japan, are interested
in the anime and stuff,
and I remember doing a Japanese class
at university on the side, and I was like
the only one in that class
that didn't really watch anime.
(Garnt laughs)
- I'm learning Japanese,
and I'm the only one
who doesn't watch anime?
- I was the only one in the room.
And I was like, oh God,
is this gonna work?
Do you need to know
anime to live in Japan?
Do you need to be into
that sort of culture?
(Gigg laughs)
But now, I think I was
just drawn to like how
the culture is very different.
One of the things I studied
was cultural discourse,
which is so boring, that
I never talk about it.
And I was really into cultural
discourse and language,
and Japan kept coming up in the studies,
and that was actually one reason.
But I never talk that, just
because it's so boring.
- I've never heard of social discourse.
So, what does that entail?
- Well, just like how,
everything in the culture
is just so different the
way people communicate,
so indirectly.
There's such a different mindset in Japan
that is so incomprehensibly different
to most other countries,
and I started learning about that,
and I really wanted to kind
of immerse myself in that.
- Yeah, I mean I think
that's definitely true.
Especially having moved
here and lived here
for a little bit, we discussed that a bit
on our last podcast
where we discussed Japan.
So what was it that made
you decide to make like
YouTube videos about
Japan, or was it just,
you decided to kind of
vlog your experiences.
- Did you plan that before,
or was that just like you turned up,
and you're like this
seems like a good idea.
- It was an idea at the
back of my head I think.
I'd always been interested in filmmaking,
but kinda threw that dream away.
Because it's quite hard to get into
the film industry in the UK.
As you guys might know, and so I was like
that's not gonna happen.
But then I go ahead and I was like,
I might make a YouTube channel.
And actually before I got to Japan,
there wasn't many YouTubers in Japan.
And I was like, I'm really
excited, what's Japan like?
I went on YouTube and there
wasn't a whole lot going on.
No offense to the YouTubers in Japan
then, pre-2012, but it wasn't much.
And was like okay.
Maybe I can fill that void and
take my hobby of filmmaking,
and my dream that I've forgotten,
and actually kind of use that
and do something with it.
So I hadn't watched a lot of
YouTube up until that point.
And I kind of drew a lot of my influences
from British TV rather than other kind
of vloggers and other YouTubers.
- Yeah, because like, I
think anyone can agree
that if you watch any one of your videos
and it definitely has
more of like a TV-vibe
than like a traditional like,
"hey guys, I'm in Japan" kind of vibe.
- It doesn't feel like
an iteration on YouTube,
which a lot of channels that
have come into it newer,
do feel like they're
trying to emulate a style,
but build on it, whereas I feel like
maybe that is what is so
unique about your take
on the J-vlogging scene.
- I mean, I don't really have
anything against J-vlogging.
- But like for me, the
thing that excited me
was the idea of making like
a crappy low-budget TV show
rather than like a vlog about Japan.
- It seems like, it gave
off the impression of like
a BBC, not a BBC show,
but like a show you'd see
on a show or like a news
broadcast about Japan,
or about a different culture, and I think
that's how I found your content at first,
and you mentioned being one of
the first people to do vlogs,
not vlogs, but like videos about Japan.
- High quality vlogs.
- Do you remember the scene back then
of what vlogs were like?
It was like the shaky cam.
- Back when, 2012?
- Yeah, 2012.
- Right, oh Jesus.
- I mean, yeah.
- It's like FPS Russia and
that's like all I remember.
(the rest laugh)
Just blowing shit up.
- I mean FPS Russia was
probably like the high.
- Epic Meal Time.
- Those are good times.
I feel like that was the golden
era of YouTube, in a sense.
- I don't know, I feel like every era,
has it's own thing to it
and I think it's easy,
to look back and be like,
that was the best time.
Forget about all those
people filming their TV,
playing cards, like looking at it.
(all laugh)
How could we call that the golden age?
You know what I mean.
- Stick a camcorder in a
shoe to like prop it up,
make it level.
- Because I think, was Sharla In Japan
the only vlogger really before.
- There was a few. There was Micaela,
Rachel and Jun, actually
there was Gimmeabreakman, Victor,
and there was Tokyocooney.
- I've come to know,
a lot of the J-vloggers
that live here, like since.
The J-vlogging community
is so small, in a sense,
that once you know a few,
you basically know everybody,
at that point, eventually.
And like, meeting Chris
and like meeting a bunch
of other newer and older vloggers,
it's really interesting to see
just how big it actually is.
Because on the surface,
I think, if you don't
know a lot of them, it
does just seem like Chris
and a few other people.
Whereas like there are just
so many J-vloggers out there.
- And that's how
YouTube works anywhere.
You can kind of easily stay
in a bubble, if you want to.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, definitely.
- How do you feel about the
current J-vlogging scene though?
- I don't know really.
I'm friends with a lot of them,
but I don't watch that much.
Because I live in Japan,
I don't really want
watch other Japan stuff.
I do my stuff, I spend ages
working on a video in a room.
I upload it and then I go off
and drive around the mountains and go.
(laughs)
Don't quote me on that!
I've kind of felt like to be disconnected
from it a little bit.
- Do you ever like see a video
made by another J-vlogger,
you're like fuck! I wanted to do that.
- Yeah, sometimes.
- Do you just scrap it if
that happens, or what's the--
- I remember I was thinking of doing
a day in the life series, and then
a YouTuber called Paolo--
- Yeah, I've seen his.
- And I was like, he's
done it. All right, fine.
- You can't do a carbon copy, right?
- Yeah, I can't. And that's fair enough.
He's done it well. If he didn't
do it well, though I think--
- But you can do it better,
- But you did something
similar, like with yourself.
Like you did like a day in the life,
of like abroad in Japan, on a bicycle.
No.
- No.
- I think the thumbnail was
like you in a Shinkansen.
- Yeah, I did it once, many years ago.
Maybe he got the inspiration
for his series from that.
(laughs)
We never know. He definitely did.
- I feel like whereas,
maybe like a channel
like Paolo is, I feel like it's more,
really 100% based on what
is happening in the video
and what's being shown.
But I feel like at
least with your channel,
there is a lot of your
humor, which is kind of
crucial to the style, and to the video.
So I feel like maybe if you did do it,
if you added your own humor into it.
But you don't want to get
in the way of the thing?
- I know if I did it,
then loads of people would comment--
- Oh, this is rubbish.
- Yeah,
- This is rubbish.
So that's my main thinking.
But he's done it well,
he's covered it like interesting people.
When I say day in my
life, I don't mean me.
A day in my life is rubbish.
It's like me sitting in a
room matching my socks, going.
(laughing)
That's literally my life, that's reality.
- Matching up socks?
- Matching up socks, it's doing nothing.
- I feel like exactly the same,
where there was a point
when I tried to watch
like every other anime YouTuber,
or everyone in my sphere
and then it just got to a point
when it just became stressful.
Because you just watch other YouTubers
and you're like, man, I
wanted to do that topic.
And now, like pretty much, I just keep up
with what my mates are
doing or some other people.
But did you guys ever go
through that phase as well?
- I did but then like
very quickly I realised
just how, again, same with J-Vlogging,
just how broad anime YouTubing is,
and how many topics that were covered.
At that time I was like, man,
I wanted to do that idea,
or I wanted to do that idea.
But then after a while,
I was just like, fuck it.
People have already done
this, I'll fucking do it.
And like, I'll put my own twist on it
and I'm sure my audience will enjoy it.
And if they're so willing to be like,
this is just a copy of so-and-so,
and I'm just like.
- I had a problem, I was doing a video
earlier this year about,
things I'll never understand about Japan.
And when I was working, I
was like, wait a minute,
someone has done this
already, and it's Joey.
(others laugh)
Because yours was like,
"12 things I'll never
understand about Japan",
mine's got 10, and I was like shit,
I can't do that.
- 13 things about Japan
I'll never understand.
- Just add an extra one.
- So I think, I'll just call
it Why I will never understand
and that-
- And it still did well.
- I don't think I ever really
watched many YouTubers,
aside from you two, I think.
And I never really worried
about overlapping at all.
Because I was pretty confident
that I was doing the stupidest
shit that was available.
So I was like, no one else is willing
to embarrass themselves as me,
so I'm pretty sure I've got this.
- You are kind of an anomaly in that.
- You were called The 93% for a reason.
- Do you know why they call him The 93%?
- Because he is a white male.
(all laugh)
- I don't know.
- At one point, my audience was,
well I'm not gonna say for some reason,
I know why, was 93% female, at some point.
- Which in the Anime YouTube
world was unheard of.
- Because it was normally,
the other way around.
- It's a massive sausage
fest, essentially.
- Normally it is.
It's dudes arguing about you know,
which Naruto power up is the strongest.
- Wow, that's quite impressive.
Is it like that now?
- No, it's like 60-40 now?
- Still quite impressive.
- At the time, I guess.
Because I was covering mainly
anime shows while doing stuff.
I was doing my prank
calls as anime characters
from shows that were like
more female-oriented.
- And that's the secret?
- Doing the British,
like the British butler
like Sebastian. yes, you know.
I would like call up
McDonald's and tell them,
oh my gosh, it's not working.
(others laugh)
- And I think like the reason why,
Connor did excel in that
is because again, he was tapping into
an audience, like a female demographic
that literally none of
us were tapping into.
- I feel like a lot of people on YouTube
are really unoriginal (laughs).
Like they never think outside of like,
if it's the anime community at that time,
it was either talk about anime,
or make a show where you talk over anime
and make them say things
they wouldn't say.
And no one was really trying to think,
what else could you do with this medium
other than talk about
shows and do nothing.
And I was like, I kind of like
the abridging, which is
like, you re-dub anime
but make them say horrible things.
But I didn't like how that
took like a month to make.
So I was like, all right,
I'll go in the middle.
I'll take these characters
and just prank call people
with them, and do the voices.
And kind of, was like a happy medium
of like messing around,
but also I can interject
a lot of my personality into it,
slowly built it up.
But I haven't done prank
calls in so long though.
- I was about to say.
- Because for me, like I.
Do you guys remember how you started
to find your style, because
when I started YouTube,
mine was completely,
here's I going to try,
and rip off zero punctuation,
and this is just my style.
- Do you remember your old
Twitter bio, because I do.
- I do not.
- His old Twitter bio was--
because I think I remember
clicking on it for some reason.
It was like, I'm that other
fast-talking British guy that--
- It was actually, no way!
- I think it was like I'm the other--
- Oh, that's so embarrassing!
(Gigg laughing)
- Not Yahtzee.
- Because that was always my top comment,
so I was just like, let's
refer to this in the bio
but the more I did videos I guess,
the more that my own style evolved.
Because I started YouTube 2007,
so mine was like near
the beginning of YouTube.
So there wasn't really anyone else
to play off of, so I just kind of copied
who I was watching at the time.
And there wasn't many
creators on the platform.
But in terms of you guys,
how did you find your style,
how did you start out, I guess?
- I mean, I don't know really.
- Do you almost feel like YouTube style
is like you just try a bunch of things
and then one or two of them work,
and you just iterate it
and then you try again
with a bunch of iterations
of like that thing
that you did yourself.
Not copying other people but like,
so you have a success as one thing
and then you're like, okay,
what worked about that?
How do I then try a bunch of new things.
And then slowly you start to figure out,
this isn't working, this isn't working.
I don't know, what do you think?
Because yours is just very different,
because obviously, lots of more comedy.
- Mine's more based off British TV,
like Charlie Brooker, for example.
- I love Charlie Brooker. Oh my God.
I take inspiration from
screen writers as well.
My year end reviews,
was directly influenced
by Charlie Brooker, fucking fantastic.
- And that is one of my key influences,
so that's something I would have watched.
And then when I sat
down in front the camera
I thought, that's what I want to channel.
And when I'm on camera,
it's kind of not me.
It's more like a, kind of more
obviously energetic
sarcastic bits, individual.
I'm not that monstrous off, I might be.
- I feel like your style
sometimes it's almost like reminiscent
of like David Mitchell.
In terms of that very like dry sarcasm,
it's just so beautiful.
I love David Mitchell.
You don't think so?
- I'd like that.
- Without the depressing look sometimes
that Dave Mitchell has his eyes.
- I don't know, man, I've been
on a four-day trip with him.
(all laugh)
I saw some pretty depressing, sad faces.
- I think just British
TV is my main influence.
I wouldn't say, actually,
I've been influenced
by another YouTube channel
as such as a result.
But what I have found is over the years,
I started off quite
strong in that character
and I lost it, because I started going
from commentating on things in a room
to doing more travel stuff.
And you can't be a
cynical, sarcastic dickhead
when you're meeting people, like,
this is your dinner and
I'm like fuck off love.
(others laugh)
Thank you very much (speaks
in foreign language.)
Like you have to be nicer,
when you are up and about doing things.
So I lost that.
But this year, by virtue of the virus
by virtue of being indoors more,
I've kind of got back to
rediscovering that character
and who I actually enjoy being on camera.
- I think it's weird you say that
because I did a video in like,
well, two videos I've done.
Like I'm trying to do some videos
outside in Japan, like out
of my bedroom basically.
- I did a video in a host club, and--
- It's a good video. I really liked it.
- Thank you. And that
was really difficult,
because, my back of my head was like,
I want to crack jokes, at the
dumb stuff that they doing,
or the really cringy moments.
But at the same time, I
don't wanna offend them.
So it's kind of striking
that balance of like,
I'm playing the fool, where I'm like
that's odd, isn't it?
I'm like that's kind of strange,
but then just moving on.
- It's a tough one, you can't,
that sort of cynical sarcastic side.
- You kind of strike that balance.
- You've kind of gotta be like,
rhetorical in a sense,
and not just be like
directly, like that's dumb.
- Because if you're in your bedroom,
and your are watching a
video or you are commentating
on something, you can really just go in
and like full on jokes, right.
So it's trying to channel that almost
that British sense of like,
just doing a little, you know little jab,
but saying a point
that's not a jab, right?
That kind of thing, where it's like,
this is strange, isn't it?
- Let's talk about that,
what was the whole
experience like for you?
Is there anything off camera or anything--
- I only heard the stories
you told me that was.
- There was a lot of things.
Because we all went there to scout
it the day before, didn't we?
- Yeah.
- Just we happened to be in Shinjuku,
and I was gonna film there, the next day.
And we were like , can we just walk
up to this host club and see what's up
and it like, looked sketch, right?
- It was pretty fucking dirty.
- They were very nice to
me, but I will be honest
and say it was a little, you know.
- No, I mean I remember going to the area
and I'm like, I normally I don't
fear for my safety in Japan.
- It was in the really
sketchy area of Shinjuku.
- Kabukicho?
- Yeah.
- That's pretty shady.
- And, I mean, what do you want to know
about the whole thing?
(Gigg laughs)
'Cause like-
- What was the most awkward experience?
- We were recording for four hours.
- So it was a four hour shoot,
so we started before they opened up
and then we went through the whole thing.
And the whole point was that like I wanted
to actually try and talk to customers,
because in my head I
wanted it to kind of be
like Louis Theroux, where he puts himself
in the situation.
So, I really wanted to
put myself in a situation
that was really uncomfortable for me.
And, so I was introduced around
by the main guy called Taizo,
and I'm very thankful he showed me around.
I don't think many people in the comments
liked him though, and-
- Why?
- He made a lot of jokes
and we cut a lot of them.
(Joey laughs)
He was very insistent
on like bashing my looks
a lot, and I was rolling with it,
I was like, yeah, I'm ugly.
- Do you think he was trying to be funny
and just failing, or was it like,
- I think there was some of
that, I think he was also
maybe a little like,
acting up for the camera.
I think maybe he's like,
this new kid comes in,
he's got subscribers.
Let's show him, what's what.
- He ain't shit!
(all laugh)
- Basically, it was like
this kid thinks he's hot, no way.
- Assert dominance!
(all laugh)
- It was just like, the way that they,
attract women, I found was like
so blatantly Japanese.
You know what I mean?
It was something really opposite
from like Western hitting on.
Like they would literally the moment
this girl sat down right, they were like
You're hot, you're beautiful!
what are you doing?
- Really?
(others laugh)
- They were like (snaps finger).
The moment they sit
down, they start hitting.
- That forward?
- Yeah.
- And you know those
girls, were just like,
you know, like.
- And the problem is that they wanted me
to like sit down and immediately
like start hitting on them.
And I was so like, I can't do that.
I like the slow game, you know,
let's talk it off for a day or two.
But it's really strange.
The way the hosts work,
at least these guys, like
the whole thing was butter them up,
get the to buy you
drinks, add them online.
Talk to them, take them
out on dates afterwards.
Be like hey, you coming
to the host club tonight?
Like it was really like weird, I guess.
- Superficial.
- Yeah, it was very
superficial and I really,
I failed to understood, how like
a lot of these girls
were really into them.
Because there's one girl in the video,
who was adamant that she was
going to marry that host.
And the host was like,
obviously he was like
of course you are. You know what I mean.
(all laugh)
Because she just spent
$10,000 on a champagne bottle,
so of course he's gonna be like
of course you're my future wife.
- What did she do to be able afford
such frivolous expenditure?
- What they told me off-camera was that
they tend to be in the
same kind of industry.
So it's kind of like they're
the same five Tumblr artists,
just giving each other.
- Yeah.
- Just giving each other
the same commissions.
- The circular economy.
- So it's weird.
- So she might be working
at like a kabakura,
and like that guy might go to the kabakura
to go see her.
- But most of them were
working in Soaplands,
so a lot of them.
Which if you don't know,
is an under board kind of,
if you Google it, it
literally says prostitution
It's legal prostitution, essentially.
So a lot of them tended to be also,
prostitutes themselves.
- That makes sense.
- And, I guess that's
why they were maybe okay
with the superficiality of it all.
- Have you ever been to a snack bar
or a hostess club or anything before that.
- I'd went to like a maid cafe,
and that was about it. But, I'd never been
to like anything, where it was like that.
Because they were like from
the moment these girls come in,
they get eight or nine
minutes each, each host
for about an hour to
just hit on these girls.
So one goes in and
then, he does his thing.
Immediately after he walks,
the next host comes in, starts hitting on.
(Joey laughs)
And then after like an hour,
she has to choose who she likes.
- Speed dating.
- It's literally speed dating,
but a lot of the girls,
just come in for the,
because you get two hours
of free 10 bucks, for all you can drink.
So a lot of the people
come in do the two hours,
and then just never come back.
I remember it was really painful
to try and hit on these girls.
Because also, I was trying to hit on them
through a translator.
I don't know if you've ever tried to
hit on someone, it's like,
- Hey ladies!
(Chris and Gigg laughing)
- It's like this distance,
we're sitting next to them,
I'm just smiling like,
you look really pretty.
(all laugh)
- They would say it back, and
then would be like, thanks.
And I'm like.
(speaking foreign language)
You look very (speaking
in foreign language).
- I wanna be your translator.
- Just like imagine being the translator
and, that's a next level of third wheel,
you know what I mean?
- And the whole thing is like obviously
I'm also drinking a lot of alcohol,
because the main host was
adamant on getting me smashed.
And so it looked like
we were drinking water,
but it was just like.
- Shochu?
- (laughs) In between the shots
that you were constantly
doing was Strong Zero.
And they would drink Strong
Zero like water, right.
- Oh my God!
- Every time they would
have to go to a girl,
they would have to finish all that drink,
they would make as well.
These were always like
12% or higher spirits,
they were pouring.
And I remember they were telling me,
the hosts in Japan they were like,
vomiting every single night from alcohol.
- I mean, if you are mixing Strong Zero
with like champagne and shots.
- Yeah, because they made me
down like a 1/2 bottle of champagne.
- How much was that
worth? How much is that?
- On the menu it costs,
I think it was like 9,000 or something.
- Were you sick after?
- No, I wasn't funny enough.
I went to Little Lamb right
after and had a great meal.
(all laugh)
- But it was, yeah.
So that was like 9,000 total
or something that she paid for it.
- So you drank like 4,000
dollars worth of champagne
in one night?
- Yeah, and then a bunch
of drinks in between that.
The shots were like $30 each
and all the drinks were like $50 each.
- Would you ever do a
video like that, Chris?
- Well, I was thinking about doing it
until I saw yours and I was like I'm not
gonna put myself through that.
(the rest laugh)
- That's what I thought,
I wondered why no J-vloggers had done it.
But I felt like none of them would be
willing to do, get smashed.
- I'm not cutting like five years
of my life expectancy for this video.
(Gigg laughs)
- But that's the thing, right.
They do it, but like they owned like
apartments in central Shinjuku
because they make like average
like $10,000 a night.
And a lot of them send to their families.
So a lot of them are just like,
making the money while it's good, I guess.
And getting out.
The coolest guy there
was the vice-president,
who like wasn't a host,
and I thought he was
by far the hottest as well.
He was like 34 and he looked like
every bishie anime character.
- Yeah, really.
- Yeah.
And he was really nice,
he was really open.
He was giving us the whole tour,
telling us everything about the club
whilst the other guys just wanted
to see me fail with the women.
(Joey laughs)
Like 'cause I remember
the main guy was, you're
gonna be supporting me.
And I turn, I just go
over, and he is like, yeah
so now you have to do
the, I'll support you.
I'm like what, I was lied to.
- Jesus.
- Yeah, and we cut
a lot of the stuff 'cause
I got really fucking drunk.
(Chris laughs)
- What's like the craziest place
you're willing to go film in Japan?
- I don't know, I've always wanted to film
in a snack bar or hostess bar.
- Because you've done the...
- Where are they?
- Well, it's basically along what
- But the other way around
with girls and guys, right?
It's far less expensive
and where I used to live in Yamagata
it's like the only thing to do.
You go to an izikaya, the second place you
always go for an izikaya party
is a hostess club or a snack bar.
Snack bars are kind of
like a cheaper variant.
- I've been to a snack bar before.
- Yeah, and there's
nothing seedy about them.
There's nothing really
seedy about hostess bars.
- I mean, it was a little bit seedy
for me because I was 16, when I went.
(all laugh)
- Okay, that's not just seedy but illegal.
- I was like in the middle
of nowhere in Hokkaido,
because I was working in the ski fields,
and my boss was like,
hey let's go to snack bar
and I'm like, four years underage to go.
And he was like, no, you'll
be all right, so I went.
This 16-year-old kid sitting there,
sipping beer or whatever.
And the mama, that's the name
that they give to the main hostess
of the snack bar, is the mama.
She just sat right next to me and
she was like, so how old are you?
- Oh God!
- And I was like, fuck, what should I say?
I guess I should just say 20.
And my boss at the time,
was like shit-faced already,
because he couldn't hold his liquor,
he was like, "he's 26!"
And at the moment he said that I was like,
I'm getting kicked out.
There was no way she
is going to look at me
and be like, yeah, you're a 26-year-old.
But now, the mama just
looked at me and was like,
you look very young for a 26-year-old.
- In Japan, if you say
you're over 20 years old,
they don't question it.
They're like, all right, cool.
- That's true.
- Because like in Asia,
especially like if you're,
because you're half-Australian as well,
so they just assume you're
fucking old as fuck.
- It was my first time I was thankful
for my gaijin face.
Like I was just like, thank God,
I look like my five years
old than I actually am.
- I would have been in
some deep shit otherwise.
But no, but the snack bar was fun.
Like it's way more chill than like
what I assume a host club would be.
- It is, I mean you just sit down.
I often take friends to
one just to surprise them
when they come to Japan
for the first time.
Because they sit down and there's like
two girls at the side, so they pull
their drinks, light their cigarettes.
- That just sounds like fun though.
- It does, but mostly
my friends are awkward,
because it's a concept that
doesn't exist really, you know.
- Because I think we had described,
that to someone in the UK,
I think people would think
that's kind of you're sleazy.
- I mean the closest thing
I could think of in like the UK,
it's probably like a strip club, right?
Where that's, I'm not saying that it is,
but it's like the closest experience
I can think of just for
like a very broad term.
- But they are far better
at the hostess place,
because they'll like be really,
they'll talk to you so much,
they'll just be full on you.
And then they'll make
you sing karaoke songs.
- That sounds like fun.
- Yeah, it's all right.
- They won't make you drink a
disturbing amount of alcohol.
- Not quite as bad as what you did Connor.
- Yeah, they definitely seem
really sleazy, the host
clubs, and I believe
a lot of them are owned by sketchy people.
- Sketchy people?
- I'm not gonna say names.
- Who's sketch people, Connor?
- You know, just some gangs or whatever.
(all laugh)
- The Y-word?
- Yeah, the games by Sega, those people?
(Joey laughs)
I'm pretty sure a lot of
them are owned by that.
Because they seem to just kind like,
operate under their own kind of like...
- Absolutely are.
- That's why I was so impressed
that they were just willing to be like,
come on in, just film it all.
- I don't know how you got
permission though, that easily.
- What happen was is, I
think our producer a Maylene,
best, best producer has every connection
in Japan, apparently.
Talked to a host, host was like yeah,
I wanna start my YouTube channel, so.
- Oh, right!
- That and apparently
if you're the number one
host in the club, you have a lot of power.
- But the thing is, that's
constantly changing.
So next week you could
be like, have no say.
So this guy was like ,
I'm bringing this guy
with a film crew, take care of him.
And to be fair, everyone was really nice.
They let us film a lot of stuff,
like how when they were
talking about earnings
and stuff they let us
film, but we cut that.
But they let us in on listening to it
and who was winning
the earnings and stuff,
and they take it really seriously.
Like they compete against other host clubs
to see who's getting the
most money between them.
And we're talking like
disturbing amounts of money.
Like I think one guy, for his-
- The one who gets the
most is Roland, I think.
Have you heard of Roland?
- I've heard of him, Roland.
- It's like $50,000 a month, I think.
Might be more?
- No, it's a day.
- Okay!
- Because on one guy,
for his birthday they were telling me
he got like $60,000 on his birthday day.
- Wow!
- Because on your birthday,
everyone has to buy you drinks and stuff.
- We're in the wrong business.
- And they asked me, how much do you earn,
for like having a million subscribers?
(all laugh)
I told them how much I
earned in like a month,
and they were like, is that it?
(all laugh)
- They were like, why don't you be a host?
- So in other words, if you're starting
a YouTube channel for the money,
don't bother, just be a host.
- It was at that moment that
I've never regretted not speaking Japanese
more than any moment, I'm like fuck!
Just to come in here like part-time,
you know what I mean?
(laughs)
- They're like, you
earn $1 per subscriber.
Right? That's how it works?
That's how the YouTube
economy works, right?
- Like I thought like I
had a nice, comfy earning
until they like, just fucking,
in front of all the hosts were
like wow, that's pathetic.
(all laugh)
- Just like a collective, like ha, ha, ha!
- That's cute, that's cute.
- Because I remember I watched
your video where you
went balls deep into a.
- Balls deep?
- Balls deep with Chris Broad.
(all laugh)
That's my channel name.
- Into a love hotel.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah!
That that was a great video.
- The owner is like a friend of a friend
and he was just the most hilarious man.
- Yeah, he was awesome.
- He walked in the room and
he's like, let's play sexy.
(all laugh)
That as it stands the ultimate one-line,
sales pitch for anything.
- Those tend to be like the easiest time
I've had recording in Japan,
is when you know the owner
and he's totally chill with it.
- Yeah.
- When you have to go
through like seven companies
and everyone has to approve.
Like I did a video, I won't say where,
but there was like
seven people watching me
the whole time, like corporate people.
- I know the feeling.
- And I was just like, all
right, can I make a joke?
Like, am I allowed to do this?
(laughs)
- Now, when you know the
owner of somewhere in Japan,
- It's so easy, right, right.
- It's fast-tracks everything.
- That was a really
great guy, Shishido San.
- That was amazing.
- Really cool,
down to earth guy.
He gave me a goody bag of like,
various sex toys as I left.
(others laughing)
And I was like,
thank you Shishido San, a dildo, great.
- He gave you a dildo?
- Did he actually?
- Also and a poll magazine of prostitutes,
like just various things.
(all laughing)
I was like, great.
Thank you.
- But you'll like that, right?
- Yeah.
- A goody bag!
- Is that the most fun you've had filming
in outside or in Japan then?
- I think it's certainly
up there, it's like top three moment.
And he did like, the opening of the video
he does these monkey bars across a bed.
- Yeah, he did, right!
- Yeah.
- And he's going (Chris moaning).
(all laugh)
- Some disturbing moans.
- When I edited it, I had
a shot of a bed, right.
You can't see him doing the monkey bars,
so it looks really dodgy.
(Shishido San moaning)
(Gigg laughing)
So the opening to the love hotel video,
the first 10 seconds is (moaning),
and a shot of a bed,
and loads of people messaged me like
you bastard, I was playing
this video in library.
(all laugh)
I was playing it around my parents' house,
when I heard these dodgy
noises, how dare you!
- I've done that so many times.
- Brilliant!
- What would you say is like
so far, your favorite video you filmed?
- Jesus, Joey. You can't put me--
- Wow, that's a really
broad, broad question.
(all cheering and laughing)
I hate myself, I'm so sorry.
- It's the one with you
and Joey, of course.
The one with the tunnel.
- I was hoping you'd say that.
- Did you see our tunnel video
recently got featured.
- You were on Chills.
- Oh yeah!
- The Burger King foot lettuce guy.
- Yeah.
- When you messaged me
about that, I was like,
my dream has come true.
- The most haunted, YouTube
channel Chills, right?
Five million subscribers.
- Yeah.
- And what was the video?
It was like top five YouTube videos,
that went too far.
- That went too far.
- Do you know Chills? Have
you heard this stuff before?
He's really-
- No, I hadn't.
I thought, wow, so I
didn't even watch a video.
They messaged me and like,
can we use your video,
so I was like, yes.
You've got five million
subscribers, do what you want.
Have your way with my video.
- He's really like an iconic meme.
- Well and then I watched and I was like,
why is his voice like that?
(others laugh)
I was like wait a minute,
have I a missed something?
- We'll show you a meme later.
- I was so happy when like,
there was nothing more invigorating
when just in that voice,
he says your name.
- Number 10, Joey and Chris go to a hole.
- Chris goes into a tunnel,
with his best friend
Joey The Anime Man, and I was like yes!
(all laugh)
- [Chills] October 16th, 2018
is when Chris bikes with his friend Joey
in search of an eerily abandoned tunnel
that's rumored to be haunted.
- I love Chills.
- I've made it!
- Life goals!
- He's the best.
- I just got a flashback.
After I did that host club video,
I got an email from a
prostitution website.
(Joey laughs)
- Did you actually?
- And they were like,
and they sent me videos
of like on LiveLeak,
of people filming prostitutes undercover.
They were like, this is
what you can do if you want.
- That doesn't sound legal.
- And so I was on the
train and I was like,
yeah, I'll open this link for some reason.
I open this link and it was like
18 plus, you know like,
and I was like, oh fuck.
But yeah, they were like if you want
we'll arrange escorts for you
and you can film the whole thing,
and I'm like, film what?
(others laughing)
Film which process of this?
- All processes.
- Do I need to like, get
approval from Brazzers,
to use their logo, is that
something that I need?
It was really strange.
I should find, I'll find the email
if we take a break or
whatever, but like yeah.
They were basically like saying,
if you wanna order any prostitutes
and make a video about
it in Japan, we'll do it.
- That's mental.
- I can totally, see you doing a video,
where it's like I tried escorts in Japan.
(Colin laughs)
- Just in the room,
here with my prostitute.
(all laugh)
- Here in my garage with my prostitute.
- That's like peak
YouTuber click bait, right?
- I hired a prostitute, not click bait.
- I tried to be an escort gone wrong.
No, gone sexual!
- Could you put me on the website?
Oh my God, and I looked at it
and it was like, it was legit.
There was like videos of like,
someone had like a
secret GoPro or something
and they were filming
it and it was really--
- That doesn't sound cool.
- It was very disturbing.
- Yeah.
- And I quickly turned
it off when they started
talking about what acts they were
gonna perform for what price.
- Oh my God.
- Bloody hell.
- And I just found it so odd that they
watched my host club video
and that they were like
this seems like a natural evolution.
(the rest laugh)
I should ask him if he would
like to hire an escort.
- You've done an awful lot of seedy shit
given your relatively short time in Japan.
A year, right?
- Yeah, I'm like the government,
please leave me alone.
I did worry if like the host club
would like raise any like
suspicions or anything,
but I was like fuck it,
I think it's a really interesting concept.
If I handle it well, it
should be fine right,
- And I mean the video did well right.
- That took forever to come edit but yeah,
enough about that, anyway.
- Yeah, I mean, shit's got real
when you see the LiveLeak logo,
that's like...
- Yeah,
I didn't even see, it wasn't on LiveLeak,
it was linked to a video
with a LiveLeak logo.
- Okay!
- It had the watermark on it.
- I was like, oh no.
- So what'd you guys think
of the state of YouTube right now then?
- Right in there guys.
- I'm just jumping right into it, okay.
- Why don't I hire prostitutes?`
(Gigg laughs)
I mean, it depends what you're doing.
I imagine that you don't have any
issues really with YouTube, right?
- No, I've got a video
coming out this week
about why I hate Japanese TV,
and I've got clips from Japanese TV in it,
and that's the first time
my video could get buggered,
for years, I've never
done anything like that.
- Do you even get like demonetized?
- No, surely not.
- I did a few times.
- Really?
- Like two or three years ago.
- I was gonna say but not recently, right?
- Maybe for swearing, if anything,
- Swearing and just, you know,
Fukushima documentary
got a little buggered
for being a sensitive topic.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I remember you telling me about that.
- I was like, spent like two, three weeks
on this amazing documentary.
- It was amazing,
I watched it.
- And I was really proud of
it, and then YouTube was like
no, we're not providing that.
And then it got no views.
- That's the worst feeling in the world.
- It is horrific, you know
I was really proud of that.
- That was an amazing video, by the way,
- Luckily loads of people on Twitter
seemed to push the video
and then I contacted YouTube
and I was like stop being shit,
and they're like, okay.
And they did something,
it kind of released it,
and then views started going up.
And so it's kind of doing all right now.
- Holy shit, that actually works?
- It works, it's peer pressure.
- What!
- YouTube,
please fix this, and it worked.
- That's the first story I've ever heard
of someone contacting YouTube,
- Just be angry.
- Especially about like
getting demonetized
or age-restricted or something,
and getting that fixed.
- And it works.
- And it works!
- You just got get in swearing.
- They remove like 200 copyright claims
from my channel twice,
so that was nice of them.
- Yeah, I was surprised.
- That was a fucking miracle.
- Yeah.
- My whole channel, I was
using an entrance song
that I bought a license to.
Turned out this guy who made it
didn't have the license to do they did.
- Oh shit.
- So I had a bogus license
and I had like 140 videos.
All my revenue just
overnight just got taken.
And I beat it the first time, because
it was being copyright claimed by him.
Second time it was being copyright claimed
by Warner Brothers or someone,
- Oh God.
- And it was like a nightmare.
So I had to re-render all my videos out
with a silent thing,
and YouTube did a thing
where they like swap it with a live video.
- Yeah.
- Which they never do,
they rarely do it.
And the only reason
they did it was because
I talked shit about my partner manager
on one of the videos.
I was like she's useless,
she doesn't do anything.
And I think she felt bad.
That could've gone either way.
That could've been like a fuck you then.
- Delete channel.
(Joey laughs)
- At the time, I was so frustrated,
I was like, my God, like I just lost
thousands of dollars every
month for the rights.
But they worked with
me and we got it done,
but that's the only time I've had like
a positive experience with them.
- The thing about YouTube is that
it's just sometimes it's terrifying
just to put your entire like livelihoods
in someone else's shoes
or someone else's hands.
Because I remember the
the biggest heart attack
I've ever got, which was like
I think it was last year,
where I logged onto YouTube,
and I just had this message
that said your account
has been terminated.
- What?
- You never told me about that.
- No, it got demonetized,
right? The whole channel?
- I think, I don't know.
- It got demonetized, I remember,
Because like Mr. Beast.
- Yeah, that was one time
where everyone got involved.
Like I don't think I
could upload anything.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if my videos were even up.
I can't remember exactly what happened
because it was like a blur,
because when you read the message.
- You were freaking out.
- What do I do?
Like, how did this happen?
It wasn't like a copyright claim,
it wasn't anything I'd seen before.
It was just like, it just basically
shut down my channel.
- Yeah, they just
took everything, right.
- They just took everything.
And do you know what sucks is that now,
to be like, to really
get YouTube's attention,
you just have to make as much noise,
- Twitter.
- As you can on Twitter.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Twitter's the key.
- It sucks though, that they don't have
a good support system.
- I know, right?
It sucks that you basically have to hope
that you can make enough noise
and you have enough of a following
or social media presence
on another platform
aside from YouTube to make enough noise
on Twitter, to be able to--
- Why did it happen? What happened?
- It was just something wrong
with the algorithm that--
- What!
- They had mistaken got,
why do I know more about this than you?
They'd mistaken you, because
you use a lot of anime footage,
that he was reusing content.
And I think they demonetize
channels that use
too much footage from shows.
And they mistaked it for
obviously not being fair use,
I think is what happened if I'm right.
- I wouldn't be surprised
if that was the case.
- Yeah.
- I don't know why, I
remember this so vividly.
- I don't know why you
remember it better than me.
- I remember more of Garnt shit than him.
I know his Twitter bio.
(others laugh)
- You're like a secret super-fan of Garnt.
- Yeah, I just remember things,
- It was just a blur for me, because,
that was the most stressful day.
Because it was like 24
hours before it got fixed.
Which, that's fair enough, 24 hours.
But 24 hours, logically you know,
this is probably gonna be fixed.
This I gotta be a mistake.
- Yeah.
I remember telling you, Garnt
it'll be fine by tomorrow,
and you were like--
- Must've been the
longest 24 hours of your life.
- Oh no, it was the longest
24 hours in my life.
- I can't imagine.
- Because actually
it was the second time that
my channel had been deleted.
So the first time my channel
got deleted was in 2011,
which is why if you go to my oldest video,
it's from 2011 and that's because
I had to re upload everything.
- Oh really?
- And that was, only back
when I had 30,000 subscribers.
- I mean at that time 30,000
probably felt like the world.
- Yeah, right.
- No, it was.
That was the most like,
my heart sank lower
than anyone had ever, than like
I'd ever felt before.
Just seeing years of your work,
just go down the drain
and it's completely out of your control.
- So that's like the one
downside of being a YouTuber.
The biggest downside, I'd say for me.
- Yeah, that sense of it all
being outside your control.
- Like 2017 was a bad year,
when they started demonetizing everything.
- Oh my God, they went so
trigger happy with that.
- They went mental. Like I
remember talking to you, Joey,
you had loads of videos.
- A third of my videos got demonetized.
- A third? I had like over a
thousand videos at that point
and I think over 300 videos got monetized.
- It was like overnight, I
remember they did it to everyone.
It was absolutely chaos the next day.
- What triggered it
again? I can't remember.
- I believe it was--
- The Logan Paul suicide forest video.
- Was it?
- Yeah.
- No, that was 2018, wasn't it?
- I thought it was PewDiePie.
- Yeah.
- It wasn't directly his
fault, but I think that
was the iceberg that--
- Yeah, I think so.
It might've been a combination of the two,
I don't know.
- Because it was right after
"The Wall Street Journal"
made the article on PewDiePie.
- Yeah.
- That triggered a ton of--
- That started
the apocalypse.
- The Logal Paul thing then
might've been like wave two.
- That made it worse,
yeah, wave two, Logan Paul.
- Yeah, that was definitely wave two.
I remember that, that was
another thing, that was just,
you kind of shoot yourself--
- Actually I talk about that
in the upcoming video.
- Do you?
- Because I was brought on to Japanese TV
on to "Mezamashi Terebi", which is like
the biggest morning TV show in Japan.
And they were like, I was like forced to
defend all foreign YouTubers
in the name of Logan Paul.
They were like, what do
you think of Logan Paul?
You're a YouTuber and your foreign,
I was like, oh, it's terrible, isn't it?
(all laugh)
And I literally just
said that same line over,
they're like what do you think?
Terrible, isn't it?
Bastards.
- Americans.
(all laugh)
It's terrible, isn't it?
I just kept saying that.
And they went home to Tokyo.
And I was like, I've done my bit.
- Was this recent, or?
- No, that was in 2018.
- I was gonna say.
- Was that the
are you YouTuber clip?
- Yes, that's it!
(Joey laughing)
- Are you YouTuber?
- That's my favorite fucking clip ever.
They just like open the
door to your apartment
and they're like, are you YouTuber?
And you're just like, yes I am.
(reporter speaking in foreign language)
(Chris speaking in foreign language)
- Are you YouTuber?
- I am.
We had to do that three times,
because the first one I just went, yeah.
(all laugh)
And then final take, I went
yes, Chris Broad and just
let them into my apartment.
And it was a bit surreal,
Jesus Christ, Japanese TV.
- I've had some pretty like,
because I've been on Japanese TV twice,
right, at this point and
man, I don't about you,
like you've been on Japanese
TV a few times too, right?
- Yeah, like six or seven?
- Holy shit, you've been
on TV that many times?
- Quite a lot.
- What for, every time you're
just talking about YouTube?
- One was about Brexit, they
interviewed me on Brexit.
(Gigg laughs)
- Are you serious?
- The day before and after the vote
they asked me, what do
you think is gonna happen,
I was like it's not gonna happen.
(all laugh)
Never in a million years, never.
And then after, obviously, yeah.
And they had me like pretend,
I mean I was disappointed. Obviously.
But I was forced to set
my laptop with my head,
like this going, looking really emotional.
- They made you do that?
- Yeah, they made me
look really sad like, I'm
like looking at the laptop
at BBC website going.
(Giggs laughs)
Because they found out I was,
because obviously I'm a YouTuber,
they were like, you're a YouTuber,
hold a camera as well
while you're doing it.
So I'm like delivering
my verdict of Brexit
while holding a camera being like,
yeah, it's terrible right now
because the economy.
- That's the one thing I fucking I hate
about the two times that
I was on Japanese TV.
It's just like-
- You've gotta be
very theatrical.
- Right, like I knew
Japanese TV was fucking scripted
out of its ass.
Just the extent to which it is
scripted is just ridiculous.
- Absolutely.
- Like I remember one time I was
on this the first time
I was on a TV program
here in Japan was, they did like
a street interview in Harajuku?
- Yeah.
- And it was like one of
those, it was a TV show,
it was like a debate show,
quote unquote, debate show
where they would like,
gather like 30 different foreigners
from like different countries.
- Oh God.
- And they would put them in to a studio
to basically like,
there's like 30 gaijins,
and then there's like 30
like Japanese scholars.
And we'd have to like debate
on like really controversial shit.
I think one of the topics was like,
should Japan legalize marijuana?
That was one of the topics.
- As if that would go down well.
- Yeah, and like I got done
on the street interview
and I guess the crew at the time
really liked my answers
that they were like,
hey we might call you back
and like invite you to the actual studio.
Because apparently I was like
the only Australian that
they ever interviewed.
So it was like, you have to come in
to represent Australia as a country.
Because like every gaijin that was there,
was representing a
different Western country.
And like I sat there,
I did a whole video on
this, which went viral.
But I sat in the studio essentially,
and they even, like
before the show started,
they gave me this full
online 40 page script
of the entire show, and
they were like, okay.
In this section, the host is gonna like
call up and be like, hey,
does anyone have an opinion?
(Gigg laughing)
And you're the only one that's gonna
put their hand up to
like, give an opinion.
- Oh my God.
- Really, that bad?
- And they told me that five minutes
before we started
filming the goddamn show.
So I'm just like okay,
I have to remember an hour,
like one hour and 27 minutes,
I have to put my hand
up to give an opinion
about the legalization
of marijuana in Japan.
At the end, they didn't
even get to that question.
So literally, it was like
a 2 1/2 hour recording.
- And the whole time I
just sat there silently.
- So you didn't even say anything?
- I didn't say anything the whole time
and they paid me 50 bucks for it.
I was just like okay, cool.
I sat in the studio
silently for 2 1/2 hours,
to just look pissed off,
because I'm hearing these other arguments
about why it shouldn't be legalized
or why it should be legalized.
And it's the most
rudimentary, basic argument
that I've ever heard.
It's like anybody with a fucking brain.
- It smells dicky.
- Yeah it's like anybody
with a fucking brain
can come up with this discussion.
And I'm just sitting there just angrily
waiting for my cue and it's never coming.
So I'm just like, I really
want to tell these people
to shut the fuck up about
the dumb ass opinions.
This is not coming. So I'm just like,
I even turn to the guy in the show,
you can actually see it in the show,
I actually turn to the guy.
I'm just like, I'm supposed
to say something in this part.
And the guy's just like,
yeah, I am too, I'm waiting.
(all laugh)
It just doesn't happen.
- Who are you sitting next to?
Like, what country were they repping?
- It was either American or Canadian.
It was a Canadian guy.
And he's like, I was for
the legalization marijuana.
Because obviously cannabis,
like all for that.
And he's like, yes, I was
going to say something too.
And after the show we
like bonded over that.
We was just like, fuck this show.
They brought us in like two hours earlier.
And I'm like, we didn't
have to wait this long.
- Jesus.
- And it's like, I basically
wasted an entire evening
for me to just publicly humiliate myself
by sitting on Japanese TV.
It was just like the
biggest resting bitch face.
And what do I get for it, 50 bucks
- You've got a video out of it.
- He got a viral video out of it.
- I got a viral video out of it.
- He got peak YouTuber click bait.
- That's the thing, right?
If you have a shitty situation,
if you can get a video out of it,
it's worth more, you know what I'm saying.
- The most ironic thing is that video,
like pushed me to over a million subs.
- Actually, I got a good
question for you guys.
What's the one time you
click baited that you like
even you look at that video
and you're like, man,
I'm disappointed in myself
for click baiting that hard.
- Do you ever Chris? Have
you ever click baited?
- Yeah. Well, probably
my most successful video
"12 things not to do in Japan".
- That is still to this
day on my recommended,
even though I've watched it already.
It's like you really like it.
- I think though with that video
the reason why I did so well,
is not because of the click bait,
but when you released it.
- I released it by shear,
I think I released it one week
before Logan Paul did a diss.
And all the comments
are, don't be Logan Paul.
Rule number 10, don't be Logan Paul.
And that's like the, you know,
20% of the many many comments.
- I was so perfect as
well, because literally,
I think it was like seven out
of the 12 things you said,
Logan pulled it.
- He done.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- He didn't even have to make a statement.
Like, a different statement.
Like that video just spoke for itself.
- Good old Logan Paul.
He got me a viral hit
and he got his payday.
(Garnt laughs)
What a great man. A legend.
- I don't know, it just comes down to like
what even is click bait anymore, right?
- I think as long as you
deliver on the title,
that is the main thing.
The video I talked about earlier,
What I, the one that you did that I did.
- What you hate about Japan, or.
- What you don't
understand about your fans?
- What I'll never understand about Japan.
That sounds quite click back in the day.
There's something tells me going,
hey with some beer looking really shocked
and it's a bit vague
but as long as the subject,
as long as the content
delivers on the title,
I think it's okay to have
a provocative click bait style title.
- It's a good argument
because like click bait,
what is click bait in the end?
There's like different levels in my eyes.
You know, what I mean.
- You feel like it happened
again and it's still going.
(laughs)
- I've definitely done that.
- It's so hard to say,
you've definitely done that.
- Joey most probably
is like, I'm so sorry.
And it was just, his flight
getting to the canceled.
It's literally his flight getting canceled
for a convention.
- I think it was called,
"We're so angry (sorry)."
- It was just like my flight got canceled.
- And all it was fucking
Allegiant airlines.
- I watched that video.
- They canceled our flight
for no fucking reason,
and we missed our convention to Finland.
- I watched that.
- And that video was
like 1.2 million views.
- Yeah I'm like this is a video
but it's not a 1.2 million.
- You turn to your title,
made it about that,
but the content delivered,
has a story, people are interested.
As long as the content delivers
and gives viewers something,
they might think it's fair game.
- Yeah. I'm not a total.
I knew what I was doing
when I titled it that way.
But I don't know, like
that's the thing, right?
Like every year, I feel like
five years ago on YouTube
you could spot a click bait
title from a million miles away.
Like there was like a
certain type of thumbnail,
a certain structure to
the title where it's like,
I'm going to get baited
if I click on this.
But nowadays, people are just getting way
smarter at titles and thumbnails.
- But I think click bait has
been getting smarter as well,
or like how to like
get people's attention,
with a really unique title or thumbnail.
I feel like part of being a YouTuber,
is just knowing the matter.
The matter is what I'm calling it.
You know what I mean?
You're like, I remember
back a few years ago,
if you had the word prank
or gone wrong or gone fucking sexual,
you'd get millions of views easy, right?
But now that does shit.
You know what I mean?
- There's a great quote I
remember from Philip de Franco,
when he was talking in a video of his,
where he is talking about click bait,
because Philly back in the day
was like the master of click bait, right?
And I think--
- He used to put tits in the thumbnail.
- Yeah, right.
- I remember that phase.
- It was genius back in the day, right?
But like he said something
along the lines of like,
with the title and thumbnail,
as long as the content is good
and there's at least some kind of content
that you can take away from it,
it really doesn't matter what
the title and thumbnail is.
Because at the end of the day,
you have to trick your kids
into eating their vegetables.
And when he said that, I was like, wow!
That actually makes a
lot of sense because,
sometimes you might have a
particular type of content
where there's just no way
you can title it or thumbnail in a way
that will get the attention of kids
or like people with short attention spans.
And so you have to be
forced to click bait,
but as long as the content is good,
and is at some level of quality,
I really don't think,
there is anything wrong
with making like a
really click baity title.
- That's always been my kind
of guiding philosophy as well.
- Because there's so much competition,
the fucking recommended feed
or the fucking homepage,
you gotta immediately stand out.
What I hate about being a YouTuber,
is that you can have
a great fucking video.
You know this video is a goldmine.
You have no idea how to
get people to click on it.
You know what I mean?
Unlike sometimes you have a video,
you poured your heart and soul into
and then you get to
the title and thumbnail
and you're like, fuck what do I do?
- Yeah.
- Is that something you
consider when you're like,
picking these places to visit?
Or are you thinking about
like, how can I, you know.
- When I making video,
the first thing I think
about is what's the title.
- Yeah.
- I think that's just
like a natural instinct
with YouTube nowadays.
- I've only gotten into
doing that recently.
Before, it was just making the video
that had a good concept and figure it out.
But I realized, I was
getting in situations,
where videos weren't doing to hot,
because people weren't clicking on it.
And then once I got into the
habit of like, get the title
then make the video around
it. almost all times, right.
It's horrible to say that, but
you kind of have to do that.
- Title and thumbnail is by far,
the most important thing
about being a successful YouTuber.
- It is sad that it's
gotten to that point,
where you can't just have like a banger,
like if you get a low click through rate,
YouTube's like, no, that's
not getting recommended.
You've got 3% less click
through rate than normal.
- Even some courageous who don't try,
with their title and thumbnail as much
as the other YouTubers, that's
a brand in it of itself.
You know what I mean?
- There some YouTubers
that can literally title
and thumbnail a video, anything.
And they just built that trust,
they are like they'll click through it.
And I like to think that
your channel is very much
like that in a sense,
because I don't really look
at an Abroad in Japan video,
and think that's click bait.
Like I know from the get-go,
what I'm going to get into,
when I see the title and thumbnail.
- But like how long have
you been doing YouTube?
- I've been doing it, eight years
as of the August, this year.
- 2012.
- Yeah. But I've only made
200 videos, I think so far.
I make far less videos than you guys.
So I have to make every video really count
for something, has to be that video.
- I think a lot of people,
wouldn't say that they are,
I know a lot of people here
who really speak really highly
of your content, so it makes sense.
But going on off that,
do you feel like the quality
ball raises each year
with like content that's
being made in Japan?
Like the kind of vlog stuff?
Or do you feel like you're
already on top of that?
- I remember, about four years in
there was a channel that popped up called
"Only in Japan" run by
a John Daub, a cool guy.
And he raised the bar.
Like I used to just be a
vlog, kind of vlogging star.
Had TV production quality,
and I was like, shit, that's the future.
So I raise my bar to try
and reach that kind of level of quality.
- And I I've noticed since then
a lot of channels also started to slowly
like creeping up as well,
with the similar kind of production value.
- Well, we'll say it's production value,
isn't as important as people think it is.
The main thing is just having content
that people want to watch.
I've made lots of videos
out and about traveling
to interesting places, but the videos
that always did the best
it's just me sitting in a room
giving a commentary on something.
- I mean, that's the thing
at the end of the day, right?
It doesn't matter how
good of a camera you have,
how good of a mic, how
good your editing is.
If you have a personality of a brick wall,
no one's gonna fucking watch you.
- I mean, that's YouTube really, right?
If you want to get a
sterilized document of a place
or documentary we can
watch something else.
I mean, that's even like, Louis Theroux,
you watch him as well.
- He's lovely.
- I fucking love Louis Theroux,
I would marry Louis Theroux.
- He is very outstanding.
- He is though right.
Because of the way that
he doesn't like obstruct.
- Judge.
- He doesn't judge, right.
He doesn't get in the
way of the documentary
but he gets just enough personality,
where like you want it
to be his documentary.
Sometimes you watch a
documentary, you are like
I wish Louis Theroux made this.
It could have been good.
I feel like you've like
almost got a really
good balance with that.
I feel like you interject your personality
just enough where it's like,
it's really cements that like,
I really wish Abroad
in Japan covered this.
- I just feel, with a good video,
it should be entertaining and educational,
there's a fine line to balance.
And that's the most important thing
I always try and focus on.
- And that's what I
found really interesting
when I joined you for
Journey across Japan.
Because you brought up the whole thing--
- Such quality content,
strapping a pillow to a bicycle.
- When you told me before
the whole thing started,
that like," I'm going to try
and release a video every day".
And I thought back to
your production quality,
and I'm like, good fucking laughter.
(laughs)
- When I found out that you were editing
your own videos for that, I
was like, is this guy insane?
- I knew it. One time,
Joey left me, one week,
I did the cycling--
- He was editing those videos and cycling.
- What!
- I did the cycling
across Japan for like two months.
And I was cycling,
filming and editing it all
at the same time.
Because I'm a real control freaking idiot.
Even though I had like two
people who are willing to edit
with me on the journey
in the car, I was like,
I'll do it. Don't worry.
- I remember after the
first day I sat with you
in your hotel room as you were like,
starting to edit over there.
And I'm just like, you gonna
be able to get less sleep?
I think you stayed up till like,
We had to get up , I think
the next day at like--
- Nine o'clock, 10 o'clock.
- 8 or 9 a.m.
It was really early,
and fucking Chris had
stayed up till like 5:00 AM.
- What the fuck?
- He had gotten maybe like
four hours sleep at most.
And he's like, all right, guys,
about to do a 15 kilometer cycle.
- How many times did
you do that on the trip?
- A lot. Most of the first.
- How the fuck did you write that?
(Garnt laughs)
- What happen is, originally
the videos came out every day,
then it's like every two
days, then every four,
about the end, then about once a month.
It was kinda like getting
longer and longer.
It's very stupid.
- I think you would burn yourself.
That sounds like an absolute,
like fast track department.
- By the time Jay was
there and Joey had left,
I was fucked.
- I saw the rapid decline.
- The life.
- It was like mental health.
- Leave my eyes.
- You know what broke my heart,
is when, is it with
Emma that you recorded.
Did you record a video with her that you--
- Yeah. She came along for three days
and we filmed the video.
But I was like, oh I.
But by that point I've
been cycling two months,
1000 kilometers.
- Do you wanna explain what "Journey
in Japan" is in case someone for reason.
- "Journey across Japan",
cycling across Japan,
from Yamagata to Kagoshima
about 2000 kilometers.
And the idea was to film every single day,
and make a video, and
show people bits of Japan
that you don't normally see.
By the time Emma joined,
he was the last guest,
in Kishi. I was just dead.
(mumbles)
I was like, can sleep now and is awful.
- It's such a shame.
- It was a real shame.
- It was such a personality.
I feel guilty about
that. I had to apologize
to Emma yesterday when I met her.
- My heart broke, because
I can only imagine like
you'd must've been at your
end of your end of the road.
- I was at the end of everything.
- And like just having like that
just unusable footage would
just be like, I'm done.
- It was a real shame.
But at the end of the day,
it was mostly a success.
We had 28 episodes by the end,
and the videos with
Joey, it was interesting
because in the second half the journey,
we went through like
Kyoto, Osaka, Hiroshima.
And then Joey, when he joined
us, he was like nothing.
- It was literally four
episodes of Jack Shit.
- The first video we filmed,
the biggest nuclear
power plant in the world.
And then there was nothing,
so we had to improvise
and make like commercials
about energy jelly.
- I was watching that, and I was like,
what's going on here?
- I was really excited with the idea
of taking a place where
there's nothing really going on
and trying to infuse some
sort of creative component.
- It was like a creative
challenge because like..
- We had challenges every day,
on top of everything else.
So I had challenges
every day and the first,
and Joey joined and the challenge was,
make a commercial in a day, 24 hours.
How the fuck are we going to do that?
There's nothing here.
So we quickly have to be really creative.
We find a train station where
there's a real train carriage,
you can go in.
- And that was purely by chance.
- That was so lucky.
Because we had no idea
that this station had just
a fucking empty train carriage
like as a thing and
was just like, perfect.
- And then the challenge,
we had to be about energy jelly, right?
So we already had that,
it was the only thing we had to go on.
And then we just somehow
pulled it off in a day.
- So it really felt well.
- It was like my favorite
video from the trip.
- So how did the idea of
the travel across Japan,
like come out?
- I was gonna ask the exact same question.
I was like, me and Connor
are on the same wavelength.
- At what point was that,
you thought about it, at
what point were you like,
I'm going to actually stop
pursuing saying this up,
and after that how did
it go all the way around.
- I've being doing a documentary,
about my friend Natsuki
and that took like
months to film and edit.
- Still my favorite video.
- And I was editing, for like
two or three months in a room.
Just like, why am I doing this?
And by the end, I was
like, I need to go out.
I need to do something.
I'd always want to travel
across Japan, by bicycle.
And I thought, this could be fun.
And that's pretty much how it came about.
And that was it, pretty much.
- This sounds like Casey Neistat,
couldn't keep the schedule.
You know what I mean?
- That's kind of wild.
- Hearing that you still
edit your own videos,
do you still edit your videos?
- I do and I enjoy that.
Like for me, the least favorite
part of making a video,
is the presenting aspect.
- That's my favorite part, I think.
- You guys like clearly like
really great presenters,
You enjoy that. For me, I do enjoy it,
but the bit that I enjoy
is the filmmaking aspect.
The latest video about
why I hate Japanese TV.
I had to learn how to use a blue screen
in a way that I'd never done before,
super impose myself into
a miniature dioRama.
And I enjoyed that, every
video is a creative challenge.
There's something to be learned,
Something new to be discovered.
I don't have the kind of personality
to keep putting out regular content.
- I think you do. I think you
have the personality for it.
I think that maybe you just, you know--
- But I don't know.
I still enjoy kind of, the
filmmaking process really.
Whereas you guys pull out,
the kind of commentary aspect, right?
Discussing, debating things,
anime, there may you have so many topics?
- I think for us, it's more just like
we get on camera, we
make a fool of ourselves.
Our audience likes it and laughs at it.
- I felt like a huge weight was lifted,
when I stopped editing my own videos.
I felt like I actually had time at time,
like time to start uploading more
because, I'm uploading normally like,
every five or six days,
so it's like constant.
- For me Garnt talked me
into getting an editor.
- No, I remember the exact conversation.
Because it was like, when I first,
went to Japan and met him and I was like,
wait you still edit your own videos.
What the fuck are you doing?
(all laugh)
- No, because I had that same thing
where, I actually like
quite enjoyed editing
and like kind of taking what I had filmed
and like making something--
- You still edit some of your own videos.
- Yeah, I edit half of my videos.
- I haven't edited a video like two years.
- I still enjoy like editing my videos.
And I think like every time
I do go and edit my videos
it kind of like reinvigorates
my love for like video making.
Cause, as cool as it
is to like hire Mudan,
who is the editor for this podcast.
- And VP, by the way.
- As much as Mudan is fucking
amazing at editing my videos.
There is like a little pot,
that just can't be
replaced, no matter what.
- I feel like it's a job that
you can pay someone to do,
and it speeds up your process.
And because the thing is
right, I'm not an editor.
If I have someone whose
main job is being an editor,
they can do the job way
better than I ever did.
And I get a huge way off.
- But I feel like to me,
a lot of your own
personality can come through
when you're editing as well.
- That's true.
- But like for me, I still,
I'm very heavily involved
in the editing of my own videos.
But, what I realized is that a lot of
my time spent editing
like pure like manpower.
You know what I mean?
It's like cutting up clips,
just making making the timeline usable.
And then afterwards,
there's like 20 to 10%
where you can really add
your own personality.
And what I did was like,
let's see if I can work with an editor,
so he can take the workload off
without making me lose my own personality.
Cause that was my biggest
concern when hiring an editor,
is my personality still gonna
come through in the editing?
- I feel that's a weakness for me
to some extent, I've never handed it.
I did actually put out an advert
for an editor on Twitter, January.
And got like 500 people,
and I was like could do,
but then I was editing.
I produced a documentary
about the tsunami,
it's a nice tsunami
documentary, about 20 minutes.
And that's something that I
just didn't want to cut corners.
I didn't wanna have to
describe it with someone.
I want to do it myself
and dive in, you know?
And I think if I was commentary videos
typically kind of settle in one location.
Whereas a lot of the videos I do off set
over many different locations.
The editing is much more intensive,
and much more complicated.
- It definitely took me like a long time
for me to finally give someone the range.
And at least with my
videos, I give my editor,
100% creative freedom, but that's because,
not only do I know that
my editor knows my shit,
and like my style, but
also because I, myself,
I'm personally a fan
of that person's work.
And I see that person's work,
like I remember how I
found Mudan, my editor,
was like he had his own YouTube channel,
and I was like this
guy is fucking amazing.
And like his sense of humor
is exactly the same as mine.
- That was the biggest thing,
is finding an editor
with a sense of humor.
Because if you're doing commentary,
you need someone who's timing.
And also, one big thing,
at least my videos is that,
especially about the host
club, if I edited that,
I'd cut out so much of the cringy stuff.
Because I see me, and--
- You want to show the
best of yourself, right?
- Right.
He'll leave that shit in
and then I'll be like,
all right, I look like an idiot.
But it's funny, right? I
look like a fool, but okay.
- It's nice to get like a second opinion
on that kind of content because it's like,
now that you did leave it in,
it is actually kind of funny.
And like, I would have
otherwise cut it out myself.
- Chris your videos
tend to be really like,
well-produced as we've discussed,
but I'm wondering like,
do you ever like scrap any videos
that you've filmed out like in areas.
I'm pretty interested, because I feel like
you're a perfectionist, almost.
- I've filmed entire
videos, then I'd be like,
nope, and deleted it. Got rid of it.
I've had videos I've made and gone,
that's just doesn't do
well, and unlisted it.
Like I did a video on Japanese
mascots, wacky mascot.
- So you uploaded it and took it down.
- It got 200,000 views, which is like,
it's a lot of views, but with the channel,
it was like half and I felt
like something was wrong
or people didn't watch it, I don't know.
Then I was like, that's not really enough.
- Really, so you just took it down?
- Yes, let's do it.
- Oh my God. I could never do that.
- I still keep remembering that video,
And I'm like, this is a little different.
- I think I remember this.
I think you were saying on Twitter, right?
This was like, not too long ago.
- I think you can just see
the desperation in my eyes.
And I filmed that at a very bad time.
Like the Fukushima documentary that I put
a month into it bombed.
And then I had the mascot video,
and I was not happy. I wasn't
funny, and that bombed.
I am fucked, like YouTube craze dumb.
(the rest laugh)
- It's always like that.
- If you do two or three
bad videos in a row,
you're like, oh no.
- I've had this conversation
with Connor where,
you know the tool where they show you,
when you upload a video,
and it shows you the ranking,
based on the last 10
uploads that you've done.
- You guys who watched this won't know,
but YouTube makes you feel like shit.
If your video does bad,
the analytics like,
your video's rubbish and
it goes all color red.
And there's an arrow pointing down.
- It's not even red, it's gray.
You know what I mean?
- It's gray, if it it's mediocre,
it's red, if it's bad.
- You feel dead inside.
- You've never actually
had an actual bad video.
- I just stopped checking
it. Because I realize,
there is basically no winning,
when it comes to checking this tool.
Because, the only time you feel good,
if it's like number one or two or three.
And, if it's average,
you feel like, Oh, okay.
- Right now with me where it's like,
my last video is like number four.
And usually it's like,
cool, it's in the top half.
When I saw that before I was like,
fuck it, it could have done better.
- So like, it just fucks with
my mental health so much.
- YouTube does do that though.
- It really does, and that's why,
I just had to stop checking it
cause no matter what, I Come
out losing 90% of the time.
- I remember when I was
like fucking obsessed
with the analytics.
- I think every YouTuber
does that at one point.
goes through that point,
where they just like,
throw at the analytics
and they just see like the,
just the most minor of change.
And they're like, this didn't do as well.
This didn't do as well.
And then the moment where I'm just like,
you know what, fuck it.
I'm just going to upload a video,
fuck the analytics.
As long as I'm happy with it, fuck it.
- I do for my mood used to be determined
by how well or how a video has done.
So if it's really well then I'm like,
and this is because I do
spend two weeks, sometimes.
- I guess the stakes are higher with you.
- The stakes are high
because I make less videos.
It has to perform well, it has to be good.
And so if it does well, I'm like, yes!
I'm in a good mood until the next video.
- In that sense, I feel
that like you and Garnt,
are probably a lot more similar.
- Because like my upload schedule is like,
one every two weeks.
If that's sometimes, you know.
Like I just went with a
month of not uploading,
and that like killed me.
- I'm in that position, right now.
As of filming, I haven't released
a video in about one month.
I've been working on it
for two weeks on and off,
try and make it perfect.
- And you are like, if
this video is not a banger,
if it doesn't hit, then
I've just taken a month off,
and I've got nothing to show for it.
- Absolutely, and I feel that way.
So it has to perform well.
So if you're watching this,
please go and watch all of my videos.
(all laugh)
- Link is in the description.
- I feel that pressure though,
by giving you that sort of approach,
you have to make sure
every video delivers.
- That's why I'm so scared to like go
to like an upload
schedule of like you guys,
or like, if with John Toronto,
or something like that
where it's like once a month
or once every couple of months.
Because, I'm just so afraid of like,
the situation of what if I upload a video,
a month in between, and
it just fucking bombs.
- I feel like, when I moved to Japan,
that's what I'm just
trying, to like get towards.
It's like trying to get
towards those big videos
at the host club.
But those videos take so long.
- Yeah, they do.
- But it was a scary transition for me
because I've used to upload daily.
- I don't know how anyone
applies daily, honestly.
- I think you have to be a psychopath.
- My first three years, I uploaded daily.
- I can see how you could kind of do that
when you're like back in the
university, or something.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
- Gaming as well.
- Yeah.
- I've been gaming in between,
so that was fucking easy, right.
- Just like well play a game,
seven parts done for the week.
- It got to the point where I realized,
I was doing more gaming videos
than actual anime content.
I'm like, okay, that needs to change.
And so I just scrapped all gaming content.
And then I went from like,
a video daily to like once every two days,
once every three days,
now I'm like once every week, essentially,
once every six days or so.
And I feel okay now,
because of like gradually
put myself in that state.
But I guarantee that if I went from
this current schedule of like once a week
to like once a month
I'd be shitting myself.
- Absolutely, Yeah.
- But did you guys feel really bad,
having to keep your schedule?
Because that stresses me out.
Like knowing I have to
upload on a certain time,
sometimes I hate having
a deadline like that,
because I have to think,
do I have the creative freedom
to try and do something else?
You know what I mean?
- This month I'll be working on a video,
"Why I hate Japanese TV",
and, I've almost finished it and I think,
wait a minute, I want
to get one more scene,
and I could add it.
- Oh no.
- I'm used to do one of these
videos for years, right?
I've wanted a Japanese TV video for years.
So this is a special event for me.
My catalyst for doing it
was, do you remember (laughs)
on Japanese TV recently there
was a clip of someone going,
(speaks in foreign language)
- Yeah.
- This is a pen. And
they did a comparison.
They had a Japanese lady, with the tissue
over her face going (speaks
in foreign language),
the tissue didn't move.
The Japanese language is
so eloquent and beautiful.
(the rest laugh)
And then she spoke
in crew disgusting
virus-spreading English.
(the rest laugh)
She says,
"this is a pen"
and the spit went everywhere,
the virus went everywhere.
It was conclusive evidence.
The English language was--
- That's why the virus is more viral.
- It wasn't an absence of mass testing,
or the widespread use of masks.
It was (speaks in foreign language),
British people, Americans speaking.
- I made a sarcastic tweet
after I saw that clip--
- I was so frustrated.
- Where I retweeted it and said like,
because every foreigner in Japan goes
around asking what a pen is.
- (laughs) Exactly, right?
- Speak for yourself Joey.
- Is this a pen?
- (speaks in a foreign language)
- Is that a pen?
- So that was like, okay,
I'm doing this video now.
I've wanted it for years
and I'm doing it now.
That is the catalyst, so
that was my main driver to do
a video on why I hate Japanese TV,
and talk about my experiences
being on TV for me.
- It's a shame for me, as well,
because like I said in
episode three that like,
a lot of my Japanese,
and my appreciation for Japanese culture
and the Japanese language,
came from Japanese TV.
Like if I wasn't watching anime,
I was watching, you know--
- Takeshi's Castle.
- Yeah, Takeshi's Castle.
- Yeah. We love that, we
talked about it last time.
- Variety of shows and as I got older,
and like into my high school years,
I watch a lot of talk shows.
Because I was just
genuinely interested in,
how talk shows work.
And I started to like growing
appreciation for that.
But then that entire illusion
just got completely shattered.
The moment I went onto one of those shows
and I realized just how
fucking fake that shit is.
- I feel in general, they're pretty,
very open about just like, kind
of like softly anti-foreign.
Like not saying bad
things about foreigners,
but just like...
- Yeah, no, you're right.
- They like to, just saying,
they do you say pen rather loudly.
(the rest laugh)
It's never direct.
It's just like, we're not
saying there's any difference
but they just happen to say
the p sound, really loud.
- Just say the p word.
- There is undertone.
Nationalistic sectionalism.
I actually did script a segment on that.
And I was like, I don't want
to open up Pandora's box.
- I know what you mean.
You want to get into that.
- And I script that, and I talked about,
I want to keep it funny and on point.
And that is a dark turn.
- Yeah.
- It's a segment now.
- It's an uncomfortable topic.
Right, people don't like--
- It is, yeah.
- Absolutely it is there, you know,
like Japan is special,
right? Japan is better.
They kind of hinted that
in the rhetoric of Japanese television.
And it was like, no, I
don't want to open this box.
- Yeah.
- It's not worth it.
- I don't want to--
- So you hate Japan?
- Yeah, exactly. I'm a
bit scared of this video
because I think it's the first time
I've been critical, to some
extent about Japanese culture
and that's something you just don't do
because why are you here?
- Why you even in Japan
if you don't like it.
- If you don't like it, leave.
- Do you find like that you
can't really be openly critical
about Japan on your channel then?
- I can, but I feel I don't
have that many criticism.
The thing is I have had very
positive experience in Japan.
I've never felt, I've suffered any racism,
in my daily life here,
in eight years.
If I had some openly racist,
unpleasant experience.
Make no mistake, I would comment on that
and I'll make a video about that.
And I've been very lucky.
And my time here has been very positive.
So I really don't have much to draw from
in terms of bad experiences.
If I did, though, I would
be the first to comment on
- Because we all know, there
are a lot of as J-vloggers
who are very quick to
like, go on like the whole,
I experienced a racist thing.
- Sometimes I kind of wished
that they would show some restraint
when they do, because
sometimes you watch it
and it's like, that wasn't
really worth talking about.
Like you know what I mean,
I was like, "they looked at
me funny on the supermarket."
- Well, I mean, not the train here.
It was like the busiest train ever.
But the seat next to me was empty.
- That's how it is.
- is that racism?
- Yeah.
- Debate.
- I think it was that. Just don't cough,
if you want to see real
fast, it's rush hour.
I'm sorry, I can't take any chances.
- This things are like that.
But I've never felt like uncomfortable.
- No, I'm just saying.
- Which is rare, right?
Because you don't live in Tokyo.
- I don't live in Tokyo,
I live in North Japan,
and I've traveled Japan
extensively, like so much.
And I very, I honestly can't think
of an experience where
someone has been openly racist
towards me or done something
that made me feel uncomfortable.
But I've kept an eye out for it.
Make no mistake.
- Because people always go (laughs).
- But people must be
going, is Japan racist,
you know, what am I going to expect?
And those bars where
foreigners aren't welcome.
There are few and far between.
And they're often in tourist areas,
where there's a bar that
has regular customers
and they'd probably just don't want,
foreign customers coming in.
Because they can't communicate in.
- They don't have that respect.
(laughs)
- Hitting on that point,
I watched a video of yours
again last night again,
I did a deep dive in your channel.
- You went really deep.
You are so good at that.
You read really deep in your research.
- I did. In 2018 of October,
you uploaded a video where you were like,
how long will live in Japan for?
and in that video you were like,
maybe like another three years.
We're getting close to that point, Chris.
And I was wondering, what are
your thoughts about that now?
Or is this going to be
something you discuss
in a video in future?
- There's still no plans to be honest.
Before I leave, the one
thing I always want to do
is to film a short film, to make a film.
- I think you could pull it off.
- Everything I've been
doing all these years,
has been building up to that moment.
Basically in my free time,
I've been studying
cinematography and stuff.
And, that is the one thing I want to do.
So I feel like once I've done that, maybe.
- If you did have leave Japan,
how do you think, like that, I mean
how would it affect your channel?
- It's Abroad in the UK.
(laugh)
- It would just be Abroad.
- Do you almost feel at times that,
maybe you're like hostage to Japan.
But you're kind of like,
well, my job is Japan.
Like, can I leave?
- Not really. You think so,
but not necessarily, no.
I mean, my channel is, let's face it
the reason the channel is so successful is
because most of my viewers
are interested in Japan.
- Right.
- And I'm fine with that.
I do have a second channel
called Abroad Perspective.
- Right.
- Clever (laughs).
- You upload a lot of videos, where
you just chat shit to the
comments that you get, right?
And it's fantastic.
- Are they replying-to-hate
comments video?
- You have a lot of videos where you just,
reply to comments and those get
just as many views sometimes
as you, maybe.
- They do.
- So I feel like, even if you did leave,
you could easily transition.
- Yeah. I do think if
I had to leave Japan,
and go for a bit, there would be a future.
I would be able to do something.
I would be able to pivot,
and create a channel
that's focused on comedy
or commentating or something.
But really I've always
seen my YouTube channel,
as a YouTube channel and
also have a stepping stone
to getting into the film industry.
And in the world of film.
- So is that like your
ultimate goal after YouTube?
- That is my ultimate goal,
and 2020 is supposed to be,
or supposed to be the
year that I did that.
- Okay.
- That's going to be kind
of been a bit delayed
Given what's going on.
- Things move slowly, right?
- Yeah.
- So you have like no interest
in staying for the foreseeable future?
- I think I'll be here at
least another three years.
I don't have a like, it's time to go now.
End goal, like I have to leave Japan like.
- I didn't say three years (laughs).
- More realistically,
I'll probably be here
permanently another few years,
and then maybe I'll transition to the UK
and I'll come back to Japan.
- Could you see yourself,
like if you did stay in Japan.
Like you've done so much
content in and around Japan.
Could you ever see yourself
at a point where it's like,
I've literally run out of every
idea that I could think of.
That's like interesting enough in Japan,
because you know like,
- You think so?
- As diverse,
and as like interesting as all
sorts of places in Japan are,
if you cover also all
the interesting stuff,
eventually you think you're
gonna run out, right?
So like, could you ever see yourself,
like getting to that point?
Or would you probably
bail before that happens?
- That's a good question.
People ask that a lot.
Like are you fed up of covering Japan?
And I think there's always a new angle,
a new story to be found,
like recently I've working on a series
about business owners in Japan.
So I made a series about
a guy that owns a sushi restaurant
and what's it like and he's a
good friend of mine in Sendai.
He owns the biggest sushi
restaurant chain in Sendai.
I've got another friend who
owns a Wagyu restaurant.
And I've been chatting with him,
and we're going to make a video on that.
So focusing on people is
another option, right.
I've never really done that.
And it's something I've
always wanted to do.
So focusing on different people.
So I always think there's another angle.
There's another story to be told.
I don't think, you know,
I've got 20, 30, 40 ideas
in the back of my mind
or written down a document that I can go.
So there's no absence of content.
- Because I feel like as a YouTuber,
especially if you're on the platform
for like a very long time, you eventually,
have to think about evolving
your content, right?
- Right.
- Because like anyone,
like if you pay attention
to the world of YouTube,
anyone who's successful in here
or has been for a very long time,
their content has to like
slowly change over time,
or you have to try to explore new things.
And I feel like one of
the biggest challenges,
is trying to figure out,
what you can kind of get away with.
Because what I fear most
is getting pigeonholed
into like one type of content.
I love anime.
But have you ever felt
you wanted to make content
outside of anime or like
something that's not
about Japan itself.
- I mean, that's like what
this podcast is for us.
I can finally talk about shit that's not
specifically about anime.
Because I do have, so many
other like interesting things
that I do want to.
I love anime, don't get me wrong.
I also like a lot of other things.
And unfortunately, I
can't really talk about
that kind of stuff without
it being very unnatural.
- What else do you love?
- I mean, I like--
- What do you love?
- What's the meaning of love?
(all laugh)
- Before anime, I was
in four different bands.
- You're made a lot of music.
- I made a lot of music,
like on the sidelines.
So I've always been very
passionate about music.
I've always wanted to talk about music.
And I did that a little
bit on my second channel,
but obviously it didn't
really pop off all that much.
- It's time to make a
new channel, Joey's song.
- The Music Man.
- Just one song.
(all laugh)
- I had a bunch of my
audience, who just like,
if you ever like start
talking about music,
it's just called The Music Man.
And I was that close to making a song.
I was that close to making a
channel called The Music Man.
- You will always be the one.
- Genius of your brand.
Your brand should be
the man, and then something in between.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And a one.
- As long as there's a
one in there somewhere.
- I mean, you have to bear in mind.
I was literally doing like Sebastian.
My whole channel was impersonated.
- I'm honestly surprised,
you manage to escape that pigeonhole.
- I don't know how I did it.
I took so many tries.
I remember so many videos
that I didn't want,
but that weren't that
fail, but I was like, no.
I know this is good.
Going to make it work.
And then like what, five years later
I'm making host club
videos that pulling weight.
- Yeah.
- You have to be
persistent, and it's hard,
because you're going to get discouraged
when it isn't normal
to what people used to.
Because people don't like what
they aren't comfortable with.
And the thing is, I'm sure
you guys will have this.
So you asked your viewers for suggestions.
And they gave you, they sound like,
do the same thing again,
but slightly different.
And It's just like, all right, well,
you clearly don't know what you want.
- They don't know what they want.
- A lot of the times.
- And you just have to be, like you said.
You found a story, you
found the people to talk.
You're like, maybe
people wouldn't click on,
when you started.
Why would someone click on
Natsuki the documentary?
- Exactly.
- But you've built it
up to the point where,
people trust you and they understand,
that you go into that kind of thing.
- I think that's the end game
with any successful YouTube channel.
It's to build it around your personality.
- That's true.
- That's something I learned quickly on,
and I spent years getting out of.
And I think you've done an
amazing job at doing that.
I mean, I watched
"Natsuki: The Documentary"
and I don't know, like if
you'd have pitched that to me
before I watched your
channel, I'd have been like.
Yeah, no, I'm okay.
- I don't know Sid Vicious'
grave was in New York.
(all laugh)
- It was amazing, it's so funny.
It's that kind of evolution
that you really like strive for.
That you hope you can make an
hour documentary on your mate.
It was just fucking around.
(Garnt laughs)
- And I think that's like a Testament
to how well you've built
you and your brand.
- And that's, the end game.
You want to build it around yourself.
You want to build it around your friends,
and find the right people to
put in front of the camera.
Like Natsuki.
- Exactly.
- Ridiculous.
- You can tell that you
are careful with it.
I feel like you're not just like,
I mean I'm sure if
there's people around you
and you're having to film,
you put them on,
but it seems very like
selective the way you
who you show and how
you show them on screen.
I don't know if you think about that much?
- I mean, I've being asking for, in like.
- Are you very like selective
about what you show?
- Well you have to be Natsuki.
(Connor laughs)
Natsuki can do so much ridiculous stuff.
You have to be very careful.
- What was his nickname for me, again?
It was Jelly.
- We did an event last year
For Journey Across Japan,
after the cycle, where all the guests came
to one room in Shibuya and
Joey was like, it's jelly.
And he thought Joey's
name was genuinely Jelly
because he'd seen Dr. Jelly,
and just thought, maybe
because his name is Jelly.
He didn't understand it was a pun
because of the Jelly and everything.
So, it's Jelly.
Jelly innit.
And that should be your new name, Jelly
- Jelly. Yeah. It's on your channel.
- Jelly The Anime Man.
(all laugh)
- That's the new podcast name for Joey.
Is Natsuki genuinely like a
really good mate in real life?
- Yeah is one of my best friends.
- Okay. Yeah.
- And that comes off that way, definitely.
- That's what I thought I was like,
I've been shocked if you were like,
we just fucking best friends.
- He is a good lad.
Those genuine relationships
are really important
and yeah that's the best bit.
It's been really fun, as
well taking that skill
off the ride as a guy that lives
randomly in this kind
of backwater of Japan
that no one knows about.
And then he's thrust into the global,
just thrust into the world
of the internet with millions of views.
It's kind of been quite interesting living
vicariously through his experience.
- I feel like we've all
done a pretty good job
in like building our own personal brands.
I'm sure if we look at our content like
five years ago it's completely different
to what I'm looking at.
- The fact that we can
make a podcast like this
and people are happy to tune in,
when it's completely
different to our normal stuff.
- I remember when I stopped
having to do like anime reviews,
it was like a conscious choice.
There was a point when I
kind of realized that anime reviews just
didn't really have a future on YouTube.
Remember back in the day,
where animate content
was reviewing anime shows and
you needed to give it a score.
- Yeah.
- Chris, you remember, right?
- I loved it, Satoshi Kon, 1/10.
- But like, it was really scary just
to have to stop doing that.
Because when you do new content,
and all your audience is like,
why aren't you doing this
kind of old content anymore?
You kind of just have to trust yourself
that you know, the best
direction for your channel.
Even if, a lot of your audience is like,
I miss you for the old stuff.
- I think I kind of got
blessed in that aspect,
because I came into the YouTube world
when the reviewing scene was slowly dying.
Because like, when you were
around, back in late before 2010
that was anime content,
like all of anime content
was like, if you're not making a review
on a certain show, it's not anime content.
- This is like what I said earlier.
People just don't think outside the box.
What's in there, and they
think that's all I can do
- Because like I would
watch those kinds of reviews
and I'm like, I could very much do that.
But I knew, that I wasn't going to be
as good as like Gigguk,
or like some other OGs in the community.
So I'm like, I've got to come in
with a different twist.
And I think in terms of my inspirations
for like my early content,
I definitely took inspiration
from just general vloggers, like Ryan Higa
or Smosh back in the day,
when they would just
fucking turn on the camera
and they'll just talk about
whatever the fuck was on their mind.
And like, I don't know,
because like my first video,
wasn't even an animated
review, weirdly enough.
I was fucking complaining about
the dub of Samurai Champloo.
That was my first review, it was like,
subbed versus dubbed, which is better?
So I really came out of the gate
with the most controversial shit.
- That's a good dub, what do you mean?
We are not getting into that.
- But in that video, I trashed it.
Because I didn't like dub, whatsoever.
- Chris knows.
(Garnt laughs)
- Bottom line is, I would
look at these anime reviews,
and I really enjoyed
them because I was like,
I would genuinely get
like good recommendations.
- Did you guys watch each other back then?
Cause you've been going,
back at the same time.
- Yes and no.
- They were like, no, I don't watch you.
- This actually transitions nicely
to the next question then,
the next topic I think we can talk about,
which is, so I took two
years off YouTube, right?
- BBC right?
- Yeah. I worked at the BBC.
- He did his research.
- I like the Wiki page.
(the rest laugh)
- Damn.
- You told me about Garnt.
We talked about like years ago.
- What did I say?
- This fucking Garnt.
I had the point when I
needed to make the decision.
Because I did YouTube when I was 17
and then I did it
throughout uni, basically.
I graduated and I was like,
do I pursue this as a job,
or do I do a normal job
and do a nine to five job?
And I remember when I finished
uni, it was unheard of
to basically make money off anime content.
You know what I mean?
Anime was like, I was at the top
of basically the Anitube's
Fair at that point.
And I had barely a hundred
thousand subscribers.
I wasn't monetized.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- What year was this, 2007?
This was like 2011, 2012.
- You weren't monetized.
- No, because monetization,
back then it was like a really.
- That's so lonely, right?
- Yeah. It was empty.
And it was like a really new thing.
And me being an Anituber,
like who the fuck gets
monetized on YouTube for anime?
So it was like, I had
basically no revenue streams
that I could basically point to
because I saw vloggers and
other people making money.
But I was like, I have
nowhere near the numbers that
are capable of make generating income.
So I made the conscious decision to like
just quit YouTube and do a full-time job.
And in that time, Joey rose up so quickly.
- This man, I don't know.
- And I'm like, holy, what the fuck?
He's getting over like 500k viewers.
What the, subscribers? What is this?
What is this world?
- It's the swanky hair.
(Garnt and Connor laugh)
- It's my bird nest of the hair.
- I know he's made with promo protein.
He was made for it, his got
a face for protein, Jelly.
(Chris laughs)
- I'm kidding (laughs).
- And basically he was in that two years,
or like two and a half
years that I was gone,
that I've already saw an audience
in the anime sphere, that
I'd never had seen before.
And I was like, holy shit maybe,
I could make something out of this.
And I remember, it was Sydney,
that actually convinced me to be like,
Garnt just shut up, you've
be talking about this
for too fucking long, quit
your job and just do YouTube.
And the I was like, fine.
I was like, I'll give it a go.
- You went from a good job at the BBC,
to doing anime, that's quite a big leap.
Most people aren't in that
position with a good job.
And then they move out of it.
- Did enjoy your job at the BBC?
- No, I was going to quit either way.
So the reasoning was,
I was like looking for a new job anyway.
So I was like, this is the perfect chance
to do something risky with my life.
And basically because I had
this thing on YouTube, ages ago,
I didn't even know if anyone's
still watched me or whatever.
So it was nerve wracking
coming back to YouTube.
Because I went to the, like I said,
the top of the Animeube game,
which wasn't really
that big ,looking back.
But it was still like,
gone from that to almost
completely irrelevance.
So I didn't know if
anyone still remembered me
or anything like that.
Two years is a long fucking
time in YouTube terms.
And so it was so fucking
nerve wrecking having
to choose to come back to YouTube.
I remember the conversation
with my parents.
When I said I'm going to quit the BBC,
and do YouTube to talk about anime,
they were not happy.
They were not happy at all.
They tried everything to
convince me to like, okay,
you want to quit the BBC?
That's fine, we understand.
Just finding another job, please.
And basically, the only way
I was able to convince them,
was I had made the decision
like half a year before.
So I had saved up all this money,
in that time I'd done nothing.
Didn't really go out or do anything.
I just put it all into my savings.
I'm like, look, mom and dad,
I've got all this money in my savings.
Just let me do this for half a year.
If it doesn't work out, I will
quit YouTube straight away.
- I remember the video when you came back,
because it was like pretty big news
in the AnimeTube world
where it's like, Gigguk,
is like super OG in the community.
Everybody knows, who he is.
Even with the two year
break, he's coming back.
Like when that happened, and your video
you where you were like, I'm
going to do YouTube for a year,
and if it doesn't work
out during that time
I'm disappearing.
(Garnt laughs)
- I remember, you said that,
in your video.
And people were like, we
don't want him to disappear.
So fuck it, let's give him this attention,
and sure enough, where you
are, now you're number one.
- All of them if you
don't support me directly,
through a direct deposit to this account.
- Cause like the biggest
thing that allowed me
to come back to YouTube was Patreon.
Did you guys experience
the same thing where,
when Patreon first launched, it was like,
if you had a Patreon,
you're like the devil.
Like I can't believe you
are trying to make money
off YouTube.
- That's why it took me so
long to launch a Patreon.
- I was always late to it, as well.
I had the idea in 2015, but
I didn't do it until 2016.
And now it's become an accepted thing.
And, Abroad in Japan pays a heavy debt
to Patreon and the folks
that support the channel.
It's enabled me to not just think
I need to put out videos every day.
I need to, like, I can actually
think creatively still.
I have to put Squarespace
in every video or audible.
I can turn those down and focus
on doing what I enjoy doing.
I think it's a great model.
- It is.
- In my own view, it's actually believe
in you and do something with it.
- Because like, it would be impossible for
so many people to do what they're doing,
including me, when I
started without a Patreon.
And it just changed the game so much,
in terms of people who
could do YouTube for a job,
which leads me onto my
next question, is like,
when did you guys realize
or made the decision to be like,
this is going to be my job.
This is going to be my livelihood.
- Well for me, when I
was teaching English,
I did YouTube as a side hobby.
And about the second year,
I had about 20, 30,000
subscribers which I was like
that's a lot of people.
But I said to myself, I'll
consider doing it full time,
if I hit a hundred thousand,
because I think from a hundred thousand,
you've got a strong support base there
to actually build up from.
And so that was the turning point for me,
a hundred thousand.
But I didn't make much money from it,
and I had to take out a bank loan of like,
I think It must've been like 10,000.
It's like make or break.
I took her out. So I had to pay it off.
But that worked because I
was able to create content
that created ad revenue,
from those videos.
I've built up more subscribers
from those subscribers.
I was able to launch Patreon.
- You have to do that.
- So there was a strategy
there underpinning it all.
And that's how the channels work really.
- Did you get any pushback
from any like family or friends
when they find out you're going to,
stay in Japan and keep doing YouTube.
- No, my family has been pretty supportive
and also they just don't mind.
So they just still be
like, you have to do this.
British parents are kind of just like.
- You don't have Asian parents.
- Telling to an Asian parent,
after their son has just gone through
four years of university
to get a master's degree
and then get a job at the BBC.
That they're going to quit that,
to talk about anime titties.
- If you were my son, I would be angry.
- I remember my dad just telling me,
I can't believe you're just
like wasting four years of my life.
- I can't believe he's done this.
- I was in my third year of
uni and I fucking hated it.
And I was like-
- I didn't enjoy Uni either.
- But it was because at that point,
I had really found like voiceover
and I had found a bit
of dabbling in YouTube.
I really felt like, first time in my life,
I found something that I enjoy doing.
I was terrified to tell my parents.
I was like, my God.
Because I was going to do
a master's in engineering.
But I was like, I'll just do
the bachelor's in my head and
I'll get out.
But I was terrified to tell my parents,
because me and my brother,
he absolutely killed it.
He was the model son.
When he did engineering did
aeronautical engineering,
went into an amazing
job and is doing great.
Perfect British son. Did the track.
And I was like, I kind of want
to just fuck around in London
and make videos, like do
some commercials and stuff.
And, so that support, they
were like, okay, we'll see.
- I guess that's the
pressure that comes with,
not being the first born.
- I think my parents said,
they haven't said this,
but they were like, if he
fucks up, he'll deal with it.
We'll help him out.
But we'll let him do.
We'll let him fuck around, he's 20, 21.
- My family didn't even
believe I was moving to Japan.
(Garnt laughs)
I was like I'm going to be go to Japan,
sure you are.
And then not a week out,
I was like, I'm off to
Japan, and they said okay.
I was literally the Heathrow Airport,
I'm going to get the
Virgin Atlantic flight now,
they're like, "yeah, sure you are."
I'm in Japan though, oh yeah.
- He will be back soon.
- This is so weird, why
is he moving to Japan?
He doesn't know anyone there.
- What did your parents say about that?
- Oh, well, good luck with that.
- How old are you when you moved to Japan?
- I was 22.
- Wow. Okay.
- Just after university.
- Same age as me then.
- And they were just like, nice kid.
- What about you, Joey?
Because you were doing YouTube videos
throughout university, as well.
- I started in my first year of uni
and then, thank God in
my third year of uni,
I went from like 50k to like half a mil.
- That was like fuck you money till life.
- My God, that must be
the best uni experience,
I could ever think of.
- I remember getting like
400 pounds of ad rev.
And I was like, yeah, guys.
I'm going to buy this rum.
It's like one pound shots.
You're like five shots.
I got this.
I was like, really?
Because in uni it's like
30 quid for an hour.
I was like, that's a pricy, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- My loan is not going to pay for this.
Where the fuck you
getting your money from?
- At least for me, it wasn't
so much like the aspect
of like, do you have enough money?
Where it's more like, you know,
because I have family here.
And I've spent literally
half my life here.
My parents knew just from how much I loved
and respected Japanese
culture and the language that
I was going to move here eventually.
And I was like, if YouTube
never like went off of me,
I was gonna move here,
and do some kind of fucking IT job here.
Because I even, interned
at an IT job here,
when I had like 30,000 subs or something.
So like, and during that intern as well,
every day I would like, just be like,
do you want to go out for a drink intern?
And I'm like, no, thanks, I
gotta record a YouTube video.
And I would do that.
I would go back to my cousin's place.
I was staying at my
cousin's place at the time.
And I would fucking come back,
and fucking record a YouTube video,
because I knew that like, if
I kept going with this shit,
it was eventually going to lead somewhere
and thank God it did.
So by the time I graduated
uni, my parents knew.
It wasn't a secret to my parents,
that I was doing YouTube.
And they were silently following me
on my whole YouTube thing.
So they saw like how much I
blew up in my last year of uni,
where, when I said to them,
I'm thinking to move to
Japan to be a YouTuber.
My parents was just like,
I mean, it seems like
you're making enough money,
you fucking go for it.
And I made a promise to my mom.
She's like, because typical
Asian parents, she's like,
I see you're being super successful.
And you're probably making more money
than most uni graduates right now.
I'll make you a deal.
If you're able to continue this
by the time you're 24 years old,
then I'll let you do it
for the foreseeable future.
But if not, you have to
go and get a real job,
at the age of 24.
I'm 26 now, still doing it baby.
- Because the biggest
thing I had to like explain
to my parents or the biggest thing
my parents were worried about
was like the concept of being a YouTuber,
as a career as opposed to be like,
you're making money, you can keep doing.
But like when, when I
quit my job, I was like,
how old was I, fuck?
I was like 25 ish, 20.
I can't remember exactly when I came back.
I'm sure someone in the
YouTube comments will know.
But it was like, you know, I was in like
in my mid twenties and like,
the concept of quitting my
career job to do a YouTube thing.
Even if I was making
money, was just so alien.
And even to me, I didn't even know,
if YouTube could be a
career that I could do
for years down the line, like,
has that been ever like
a worry for you guys?
Like how long you can
basically do this for.
- I've always thought to myself,
because it's really hard with YouTube,
because, as of right now,
there is no previous example
of someone being able to
do this for like 50 years.
It's not like every other industry,
like the movie industry
or the music industry.
Where there are examples of people
who have been able to do
it their entire career
from like the twenties to the seventies,
because YouTube is not even
15 years old at this point,
we don't know if it's
going to be the next TV
or if it's just a fad.
- Get ready for Tik ToK.
- You never know, honestly.
So like that's what's like
the scariest thing about it.
And I think that's why I've slowly come
to the realization that,
like, I can't put all my eggs
into the YouTube basket,
because you really don't know,
if it's one day it's
just going to disappear.
- Do you have a plan or anything?
If YouTube fell through,
wouldn't you have like a backup?
- I guess for you would
be the film industry.
- That will teach English again.
Back to teaching Japanese students
how to pronounce the word salmon.
(speaks in foreign language)
- How to say without
pen pronouncing the p.
- This a pen.
That's my backup plan.
Yeah. It's just like.
- I haven't thought about it.
- I believe that it'll be all right.
I'm seeing YouTube Weill will be okay.
We talked about the turmoil of YouTube,
how dodgy it is, but
at the end of the day,
YouTube is fairly stable
and it is fairly okay.
- It's more sustainable
than I think YouTubers
like to make out of it.
We like to play devil's advocate, a lot.
- Definitely. And I've got
a podcast I do as well.
Occasionally I do sponsor stuff.
I've got Patreons.
So I have lots of different avenues.
If YouTube falls, then hopefully
I can bounce back somehow.
Make my transition to the film industry.
But that's why I do have my
eye always on the future.
You get the film, moving to
TV, doing something like that.
As a backup. But then the day really,
YouTube will always be for
the foreseeable future,
hopefully 10 years.
That's my main bread and butter.
That's what I do.
That's what I enjoy doing.
- The way I see it, as
well as like, you know,
it's not often you get
an opportunity like this
in your life.
Even if it did fall
through so fucking what?
I had a good time.
- Even if you were like a millionaire,
if you were worth $500 million Connor,
you probably still do what you do.
- It's what I'd love to do.
- You don't do it for the money.
You do it because you
actually enjoy commentating.
You enjoy the creativity, enjoy the fun.
And I'm sure that's like you guys, right?
- Yeah.
- I love the creative aspects for it.
Like I went through four
years of engineering
to realize I don't want to do engineering.
You know what I mean?
- I feel like that's engineering.
I did engineering, as well.
You did three years of
engineering to realize,
I think I like engineering, like I do.
I remember, I distinctly, I remember this.
I was in my dissertation,
my final dissertation
and I did some electrical
engineering for it.
And I was like, I think I
like electrical engineering
more than--
(the rest laugh)
And I was like, fuck.
It's like, kind of like shit,
I've been doing mechanical
for three years.
- Did you have a diploma
or did not have a diploma?
- I got a certificate from high school.
- Special boys studies.
Now I did business and
English linguistics.
- How long did it take for that?
- I guess that was three years.
- And then straight to Japan?
- And then straight to Japan.
But I felt like that is a litmus test.
If you had like a billion dollars, right?
You still will probably want
to do what you do now, right?
You want to live in Japan.
Experience the country,
upload so many videos,
and see people.
And that is the main thing, right?
That's the main test,
If you enjoy it or not.
- I've always wanted to and I think
the other boys can attest to this,
but like I've always wanted to ask you
and I'm pretty sure I've to
ask you personally about,
how you got to do your Ted.
- I completely forgot about that.
- I fucking love Ted talk, as a meme?
- Yeah.
- It's like, welcome to my Ted talk.
Right. Like I love that part.
So we want to know how you got that.
How that opportunity came up?
and like, just walk us
through the whole process.
- Somebody said, "do you
want to do a Ted talk,
about being a YouTuber in North Japan,
and talk about what it's like."
- Is that Tohoku University?
- Yes, Tohoku University which is one of
the top three university
in Japan actually.
And they were like, do I do a Ted talk
on how YouTube can be used as a way of
encouraging people to come and talk?
And I was like, yeah right.
But I'm quite nervous at public speaking.
Because it's quite scary
going you doing this,
where it's three, four
drunkards in a room,
just standing in front
of a Canon DSLR camera.
To standing in front of 2000 people going,
Excellent. Brilliant, wonderful.
- Absolutely. It's because
like there's no feedback.
You're just talking to a camera.
- I fucking love making a fool of myself
in front of people. I don't know.
I think I'm too British and
I want to do a TED Talk.
- I would like unironically say like,
I would love to do a Ted Talk.
- What about?
Talk to Jelly.
- Honestly, if someone was
like, can you do a Ted Talk
about white animes or
something, I'm like, fuck yeah.
- Exactly, it's gotta be
something you're passionate about.
And then I'll speak to
him about how YouTube is
a great tool for breaking North Japan.
I had lots to say on the subject,
given that I'd done it for
five years at that time.
- I saw the video and you
seem like quite natural.
- I was the last fucking
speaker of the day.
And I was like, as I said,
I'm nervous doing public speaking.
And this is the biggest
speech I've ever done
in front of a crowd.
Was it like 2000 people or something,
and everyone's talking
and I'm the last one,
I'm just sitting there like, just shaking.
And then you go up and you're
like, I need to act cool.
And I'm like, yes. And there's
like a timer, before you.
I've got like 15 minutes ago.
14, 14:59, 14:58, 14:57,
This seems good, isn't it?
And the people love YouTube.
- Was there a part of
you where you're like,
should have timed this to one minute,
and I went 10 seconds over.
Oh my God, I've got to speed the rest.
- I remember watching loads.
I remember I watched Ken Robinson,
which is a really good Ted Talk.
Ken Robinson talked about
how schools kill creativity.
It's when the best speeches on Ted.
And one of the biggest, most
viewed, it's a great speech.
And I just thought, I'll just do that.
I watched Ken Robinson
speech, like 20 times.
I'll just walk him, across stage
and I'll deliver lines
like this, in intonation.
And I remember I comment like
mimicking his intonation,
I'm just like Ken Robinson and it worked.
- Did you do like a little of prep?
- I scripted the speech
and then in my apartment,
the day before,
I literally just did it
10 times, 10 times go.
And I just did it once, I did it twice,
like a tally chart
and I was like five
times cross, six times.
And that's all there is to it.
And that wasn't too bad.
Cause obviously you can just wing it.
I did a Japanese speech contest once,
and then that was extremely difficult,
because it was in Japanese,
and you're not allowed to
deviate from your own script.
Cause the judges had your
script in front of you.
So you have to go word by word, perfect.
And so I'd done that.
And that was obscenely complicated.
- What was the process of that?
Like how did you get into that?
- I had to focus on like one
paragraph a day over a period.
- How long was it?
- It was a 15 minute speech
delivered entirely Japanese.
I wrote it in English,
translated it and perfected it.
And then I just broke
it down into paragraphs.
Used a memorization
technique to get through it.
- At that point, how good
was your Japanese speaking?
Like conversational?
Lasting conversational?
- I was conversational.
I'd be learning Japanese
two years by that point.
- Okay. Yeah.
- And they gave me four,
I'd done another speech
contest and I just forgot it.
I got like three paragraphs.
I was just like (speaks
in a foreign language).
Fuck, I forgot it.
I just bombed.
So I had to read off a sheet
and it was really awkward.
I was like, I've gotta
learn from that experience.
- The next year, I'm gonna fuck
this fucking speech contests.
I'm going to do it.
And it worked, I went all out.
But so doing that really
prepared me for the Ted talk.
And after that Ted talk, I was like, okay,
I don't feel that nervous
about public speaking anymore.
- Would you do another Ted
Talk, if you got the offer?
- Sorry.
- Would you do another Ted Talk?
- Yeah, probably. I don't
know what I'll talk about.
- About how awesome Japan is?
- The value of Strong Zero?
(the rest laugh)
- Why the West needs Strong Zero?
- Because that sounds
like my worst nightmare.
I hate public speaking and
I've only gotten better
about it because I've done panels,
and it's like a fight or
flight kind of situation.
- Once you've done it a few times,
you do learn to enjoy it.
- Yeah.
- We just dragged him out recently,
to do a video shooting in public,
that you've never done before.
- That was hell for me.
- It's not out yet.
It's actually going to be
out like in this weekend.
- It's out by the time of this recording.
- Basically we went around Akihabara,
and buying as much stuff
as we could for 500 bucks.
Yeah, this is all the stuff.
That's the challenge.
And we had a bunch of
challenges and he'd never done
any video, anything like that before.
And it was really fun seeing
him like, suffer slightly.
- Were you guys like spotted in public,
while you were filming.
- Yeah. I mean, we got
permission to film where we did,
but there were still like people there.
But I think the biggest thing for me,
is that I'm just like,
my videos have scripted.
They're like perfectly planned,
perfectly like I know
everything that's going to.
So like when you just stick
a camera in front of me
and just expect me to just talk.
Unlike the podcast is different,
because I got you guys,
it's like a conversation.
I need that conversation.
I need that bounce back.
Because if it's just a camera,
I kind of speak,
and I almost like instinctively
wait for response.
And then I realized that
no response is coming.
So I started panicking.
So I'm like, did I make the
points I wanted to make?
And it's like, the first time
I tried filming the intro
for this video, I was just like panicking.
- People are looking at you?
- Yeah.
- I just wasn't used to it,
but because, I remember my first panel,
and I was equally as nervous
for my very first panel.
And it was, back then, it was only
in front of like 50 people or something.
- Have you've been trying
to make convention?
- I haven't, I got invited to a few,
but I felt like I was misplaced.
Cause I literally, if it's
about Satoshi Kon, we're in.
(Garnt laughs)
- I feel you'd be good
on the panel, like Garnt.
- Maybe if it's about Japan stuff.
Yeah, maybe. I don't know.
- Yeah. I mean, if you're talking
about something you know about,
and you're passionate about, it's easy.
Because my experience with public speaking
had come from school, right?
Doing presentations in university,
that's actually worth
something for your final grade.
It's just like, fucking awful.
- I gave the fucking worst
speech for my dissertation.
My dissertation failed completely.
I had built these renewable energy devices
that just did not fucking work.
And they were so poorly made.
And I had to like, it's
like selling a product
that you know doesn't work, to someone.
And I remember saying that,
and I knew within like two minutes
of this like 10 minute
speech that my professors,
they knew it was fucking cheap.
And I had to keep selling it like,
but it's very renewable, you see.
And when the water comes up,
the magnet will power.
I was literally explaining
like basic physics to them.
And it should have been
like way more in depth,
then somehow they gave me a good grade.
I think because I was hopefully
at least somewhat charming.
- Because it was very renewable.
- I was just like playing it off.
And I'm like, well, I guess it just,
I remember it should
work, but it just doesn't.
(Joey laughs)
Because I didn't make it work.
They started laughing
and I'm like, all right.
- Well the joke's in.
- I genuinely think the jokes saved me.
- Yeah.
- Cause they were like,
I wasn't fucking awful.
- Here's a thing, I remember
back in my university days,
I kept the fact that I was a YouTuber
or did YouTube videos completely secret.
- Same.
- How because
my roommates found out
immediately when they heard me
fucking making anime
screaming noises in my room.
- Because like any time I would record,
my housemates would be like,
are you practicing for a presentation?
And I was like, yeah, I was a
practicing for presentation.
They believe that.
- Dude, I remember doing like moaning
for a character or something.
And I came out from my room,
they were all just outside looking at me
and I was like, hello, I'm going
to go get a glass of water.
- I see because when I was at uni,
I was like attending uni from home,
like from my parents' place.
So like I had the privacy.
So I had to travel like two hours, one way
to like go to uni every day,
and then two hours to come back.
And so, the only people who heard me
was my sister and my parents
and I wasn't like doing weekly.
- Equally questionable.
- I wasn't doing like weird moaning shit.
- That's all you, man.
- I'm still stuck true to myself.
- I was unlucky because
obviously I was a teacher.
And then in my second year,
my channel really took off.
I don't know how my
students found out about me,
because they did.
And so every time I went
from being Chris Sensei
to YouTuber. And as
walk along the corridor.
(speaks in foreign language)
And that's kind of awkward and weird.
- You should have
corrected them being like,
it's Abroad in Japan.
- It's quite an awkward situation.
So I have 1200 students shout
at you being like YouTube.
- Isn't it so strange now
how we've gone from that
to like, at least in Japan,
all these young kids
wanting to become YouTube.
- Yeah. That's right.
Like if you ask kids
nowadays, they tend to say,
they want to be YouTubers,
they want to be rockstars.
- Like sports stars or
something like that.
- And I'm like why?
- I mean I get it.
But at the same time, it's
very stressful at times.
- I feel like. if you're
not mentally strong enough,
it can really break.
- No but for me, compared
to getting a 100k,
getting a million for some
reason didn't feel as good.
- It just Like it ticked over.
It's like when your car hit
a hundred thousand miles.
- And it's just like, I
feel like mental health
and just taking care of your mental health
is such an important thing to think about
when you becoming a YouTuber.
Nobody really thinks
about that when they say,
I want to be a YouTubre.
- You've certainly got
to grow a thick skin.
I do read most of my
comments on my videos.
I feel like, when I make a video,
it's like hosting a party,
and you want to be there for the party.
You don't want just make
a video, then fuck off.
You want to be there for the house party,
mingle with the guests and
then go to sleep at 4 a.m.
And I love that.
But if you do read the comments,
they'll always be the ones
that like, "you're fat now."
- Your comments are fucking a brutal.
- Like someone commented and said,
you look like a retarded Elon Musk.
(all laugh)
- Those are funny though.
I think it's the ones where
they do the littlest jab,
really gets you.
Where they might have said something
about one thing in the video
you are insecure about,
and it just ruins you.
You're like, fuck my whole day is ruined
because of that one comment.
It just hit the right thing.
- I got my fair share of that when I was
on your Journey Across Japan.
- One thing you always get it when,
as a new person, a channel.
A few guests got that, wasn't just you
on Journey Across Japan.
Like my good friend, Pete,
who I do the podcast with.
He got that as well,
because he was a new guest
and is very different.
You always gonna get that, I think.
- I mean, how do you guys
deal with hate comments?
Or like how--
- I don't.
(Garnt and Joey laugh)
- I feel like, as a YouTuber,
what a normal person would consider hate,
and what a YouTube ever can see.
You have to really push
that like goal to like full.
Because if you consider
even the slightest thing,
you can--
- Yeah. That's the thing.
It depends on what they say, right.
If it's something very opinionated,
like I just don't like
so-and-so because I just don't.
It's like, you can't
really do anything about it
because that's just their opinion.
But when it's like really persistent,
and really petty that's when you're like,
what's your issue?
- In fact some of those funny,
like I said earlier,
the ones where you find
that one thing you're worried about.
- That specific thing.
- They somehow find it.
- They know what you're insecure
about, there's a one thing.
Like you can have like the
worst hate comment in the world.
And like sometimes it's
like a one sentence comment.
Just like bothers you, for the entire day.
- I've had comments
like you're an asshole.
And I'm like, that's funny.
(Garnt laughs)
But then they'll just like,
I can't remember what it was.
I read I've read one recently.
I was like, fuck you, you got me bitch.
(Joey laughs)
I hate you so much.
And that was it.
- So what are you my therapist?
- Yeah, just like that.
They just hit you in like,
where you're insecure about it.
And you're like, goddamn
it. Like they got it.
But you just kind of learn.
That sucks, but I've got done with it.
If I let it affect the
videos then, you know.
- I feel like the craze,
that phase is over,
about hate mail reading comments.
You know, reading these videos.
That was really fun.
I feel like you can't
really do it anymore.
I feel like it happened
like three years ago.
- It was really popular in 2000s .
- It was.
- I did one like three years ago.
- I've done three videos
and rode that wave
and viewers always loved it.
Because the comments I used
to get, just ridiculous.
Like I hate British men
that speaks with the mouth like pit bulls.
(Garnt laughs)
That was so good.
- So many comments are just so brilliant,
you want to we put on a t-shirt.
- It's when you pin the good comments.
- Yeah.
- Such a good insult.
You're like, I'm a pin that.
- I used to hate when they call me faggot.
I hate the word, faggot.
- They called you that?
- Yeah, you're a fucking faggot.
Because in the UK we have faggots,
which are like meatballs.
I'm not meatballs.
All right, yes, North Americans.
- Yeah.
- That word always drove me up the wall.
- Because I feel like--
- You adapt, right?
You adapt, you learn.
- It kind of sucks, right?
Because like, as anyone
like any influencer,
I gotta hate using that word.
The words I don't want
to be associated with me
but it still associated with me.
- It's my second least favorite word
next to content creator.
- Like a lot of questions I get
from like other smallest creators like,
how would you deal with hate comments?
How did you not let that affect you?
And I think it fucking sucks
that all we can say
is, you get used to it.
And that's not a solution.
That's a fucking coping mechanism.
You know what I mean?
- That's a part of the job.
Do you remember, when you
started uploading first
and you got that first dislike
and you were like, who fucking did this?
Who disliked this? How?
And then now you just accept that
for some reason you'll have a thousand.
And you're not really sure
why you have a thousand,
but you're like, that's normal.
I expect a thousand.
And then when you dunk at a thousand.
- But when you think about it like,
when you think about a
thousand people surrounding you
who just fucking dislike you.
It's like, oh, okay.
- It's weird. But I remember
there would be like,
I had a friend who when they started out,
they had like a mental breakdown
when they got a dislike.
They were like, who disliked it?
No one at the comments
said that they disliked it.
Who did this? Why did they do it?
And it's like, you just
got to deal with it.
You've gotta get over it, I'm sorry.
- Because like I remember
one of the hardest lessons
I had to learn, was just learning
that you can't please everyone.
And especially, I remember
a point when it seemed
like everyone was positive
about what you were doing,
you didn't really get--
- That's how it is.
- And then, you reached this point,
when people would just start
hating you, as a person,
or they personally
dislike your personality
or something about you.
And you're like, I don't
know why you dislike me.
I've never met you.
I never seen you, but
you seem to dislike me,
and I'm just like, having to learn
that there are just going to be people,
that dislike you,
is like one of the hardest
things I've had to learn.
- It's still a thing, I think.
I still like have to
like come to terms with.
Some people will just kind of dislike you.
And it's actually, you
have to accept that.
- I feel, especially when like,
you know, when again like,
because the large majority
of YouTube is American.
And I don't want to say like,
Americans don't get sarcasm,
but, a lot of them don't.
All four of us are very
well versed in that sector.
- When you do any form of jokes,
it could fall flat, onto that person.
- The thing that annoys me is when people
get angry about me swearing.
- Yeah.
- That's so really
common. I get people like,
stop, you're ruining
Japanese culture by swearing.
I'm like yes, me speaking
words is in ruining
an entire culture back there,
three, four thousand years.
Words can bring down a
culture, that is hypocrisy.
That is fucking stupidity.
- Swearing in the UK is so
ingrained in the culture.
- It is.
- Yeah.
- I think in Australia, it's much worse.
There are many c-word.
- Every video I said cunt like
two or three times, at least.
And there would always
be that one comment,
which is like, I don't like
it when you use the c-word.
I'm like, get used to it, cunt.
- Have you heard Americans
say the word cunt,
it's like, with your mates
in England or Australia,
you say it all the time.
Like, "all right cunt, how you doing?'
But when you say an American,
you want to hear an American say,
you're like wash your
fucking mouth, please.
- It's so elongated in American.
- It's the hard c.
- It's the hard r as well.
Because the way, we tap
the r, in the British.
But in American, the r, is a full sound.
I'm a retard.
- There's no r in the
word cunt, like honestly.
- I was like, wait a minute. I don't know.
- I was thinking about a
different thing, I'm sorry.
(the rest laugh)
I've lost my mind.
I don't know where I'm going on about,
just take care of her, I'm out.
- No, but like, yeah.
I definitely, like, I still get comments,
which are like, "I don't
like it with you swearing,
because my kids are into anime,
and I don't want my kids to be affected
by your dirty language."
- Anime titties all the
time, what do you mean?
- And it's like, let me
do what I want, dude.
Like, I'm sorry that your kids
don't like when I say fuck or cunt.
But like, I'm sorry, that's just me.
- Because like to me as a Brit,
like the word, fuck, is just
like a filler word, sometimes.
You know what I mean?
Like sometimes you just
thinking, you're like,
what was I fucking saying?
- Fucking in British
and Australian language
is like the equivalent
to like the word, really.
Where it's like, it's not really hard.
It's fucking hard.
- We obviously weren't brought
up in a Christian household.
- My parents hated me swearing,
but that's another story for now.
- My dad certainly sweared, like I said.
- He is Australian, doesn't
matter, that's like normal?
- Yeah.
- Well, we ain't got
anything else to talk about?
- I know, I think that's
everything I had in mind.
- Do you want to shout anything out Chris?
- News, TV, video, or any?
- Yeah. Watch Abroad in Japan.
- Check out Chris's
channel, in the link below.
- When is this video coming out?
- Early July.
Well the video I've talked about now,
it's come out already.
So you should check it out,
on Abroad in Japan channel.
- All right, we'll link
you in the description.
- It's been a lot of fun.
I've not been in a room with
like two other British guys
in about eight years or so.
- Really?
- When in Japan, and
the Australian person,
it's just a bonus, isn't it.
(the rest laugh)
It's been an exciting
transcendent experience
to come to the anime church.
So thank you, very much.
- Actually, before we end it,
we're going to make it a tradition,
that every guest has
to like sign something.
- Oh wow.
- So we we've like
prepared like a shikishiki.
- This is the Japan style thing.
- Yeah.
- Every bar or restaurant
in Japan, they have these.
- We will be honored to have you sign.
- We have like this
blank wall at the back.
- Yeah.
- So I figured, why not
with every single guest
that comes into the show,
we get them to sign this.
And so that, do I have to
write a special message, or?
- Whatever you want to feel.
- Whatever you like
- In the meantime, thank you
to our wonderful Patreons,
for supporting this episode.
Our names are on screens right now.
- So if you'd like to support the show,
and help us bring in more guests,
like Chris or other people,
then you're spot on Patreon
is greatly appreciated.
- Yes. And you know, if
you enjoyed having Chris on
and, you enjoyed having guests on,
leave a comment as well.
Because this is new for us as well.
This Chris is finally our first guest.
You guys have been talking
about this empty microphone
since the first episode, I think.
(Garnt laughs)
What did you write?
- He said, I love you
guys. Especially Jelly.
And then, his tiny
signature at the bottom.
- Fantastic.
- Well that's going on the wall.
- God bless jelly.
- And here he is.
It's gone.
- I know we're supposed to end here,
but can I just quickly talk about
how the first time I had to like,
when someone asked you to
sign something as a YouTuber
and like you realize,
you don't have a signature
as a your YouTube.
- I have a doctor signature.
(Garnt laughs)
- My signature that I use now,
was the first time I ever signed something
and I was just like,
fuck, I'll go with that.
And I'm fine with that, for
like the past four years.
- My signature as Gigguk looks better
than my actual signature.
Like my actual real name signature
is like fucking squiggles.
But there was this one time,
when someone asked me to
sign something on a panel
and I just signed it and he was like,
can you gotta sign it again?
I can't really read this, smells like oh.
- I mean look at the--
(Garnt laughs)
I can make on the sea, but.
- It was the pen's fault, not me.
- What is that supposed to be,
there's a c and..
- I'm not explaining.
- Amazing job, thank you.
- Thank you very much Chris.
- Yeah, Jelly!
- We hope you enjoyed this
episode of Trash Taste.
I've been Gigguk and here
with me has been my cohost,
the handsome man, Cdawg and Chris.
And we will see you guys next time.
- Bye.
(upbeat music)